That's literally turning,
Wash Shahada,
a beautiful voice man.
Sweet,
right?
Like an angel.
Tommy.
So good rod.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by ting.
Ting is one of our favorite sponsors.
It's a,
it's an awesome company.
I great cell phone company that works on the sprint backbone but at gives you a
lot of options as far as like,
um,
what you can do with your,
uh,
your account.
Um,
they don't have any contracts.
You can cancel at any time.
Um,
I love this part.
No overage charges or penalties.
If you lose,
you used more time than you thought you would.
You just pay for what you used and credit on unused service.
This is unheard of.
If you use less than you thought you would,
10 drops you down to the level you hit and the credits that difference on your
next bill.
I mean,
that's fucking incredible.
That has way too fair.
It's beautiful.
Nobody does that.
It's such a thing.
It's a really cool idea.
It's like do business,
but do it ethically and do it in a way where people aren't being fucked.
It still going to get plenty of business.
There's 300 million goddamn people in this country.
How many people do you need?
Oh,
I know.
I mean,
how much,
how much money do you need?
You wouldn't you feel happier if you had,
you know,
whatever,
uh,
enough.
But it's,
it feels good.
Like you're doing everything you should be doing with a company providing an
excellent service.
It's,
it's on the sprint backbone,
one of the biggest cell phone services in the country and they use these awesome
phones.
They have these,
I was telling you,
the Samsung Galaxy s three,
and they have the,
uh,
the note and the note to,
Oh,
these things are insane.
Isn't it?
Crazy?
Beautiful.
Yeah.
It gets some notes in this.
I know.
We need to get some notes.
It makes me think the,
uh,
it's crazy when you hear that a company is so ethical that it makes you go like,
what's going on?
Yeah.
You guys are the CIA.
Why are you guys being on,
you know,
why am I doing so much sneaky shit?
This is a real tendency with companies to try to make as much money as possible
to maximize their profits,
you know,
and the more they maximize their profits,
especially corporations who are dealing with many,
many employees like who knows how many a hundred,
a thousand,
whatever it is.
When you're dealing with all those people and if you want to maximize profit and
they're trying to maximize profit collectively over a group of like hundreds of
people where it makes an impact on either one of it,
there's a lot of fucking money involved.
It's what I'm trying to say.
And there's,
there's got to be the correct ethics in place.
And I think for a lot of companies in this country,
they're not,
I think a lot of companies there,
they're just trying to make as much money as possible.
But smart people like Tang are saying,
you know what,
you can make plenty of money and still be really fair and that's good money.
That's the new concept.
And it's a great concept.
You know,
the same with hover.
Hover is,
um,
a domain name company that is also owned by 10.
And they have sort of the same thing going on.
It's beautiful.
Go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible] dot com and you can get 25 bucks off of either
one of their cell phones or service.
And then like I said,
they have top of the line android phone.
That's pretty dope malicious.
I used mine in Columbus,
Ohio at work to everywhere actually worked better than my 18 t phones.
I was using my,
uh,
I gotta tell you to,
Joey loves sprint and he says the prince amazing.
And I think sprint is probably commensurate with Verizon as far as the areas
that you can use it because it's a CDMA,
you know,
I think CDMA is,
um,
it's,
it's a different sort of a signal than GSM.
That's why Verizon is so good.
One of the reasons why it doesn't drop as much as like that CDMA can go like
deep in the buildings and shit.
It's a,
apparently it's older technology,
but it's a little bit stronger.
Just,
sorry to tell you one that has that one.
Verizon and sprint or CDMA,
whereas a t and t,
um,
t-mobile,
those are GSM.
So it's different kinds of stuff.
Okay.
Yeah.
But GSM is more worldwide,
like use GSM,
you're fine.
And Europe,
all,
all throughout England.
If you have a Verizon phone and you go over to England,
you're fucked.
Really?
Yeah.
You have to get a world phone.
It won't even work without that.
No,
you have to get a world phone because if you,
you're a,
you're running on a CDMA signal.
They don't use that old stupid shit.
Oh really?
It's only Americans that used that.
I don't understand why it's better,
but I do know that an 18 and t you can go online as well as,
um,
as as make a phone call.
Like I could be talking to you.
And then I said,
well,
let me look it up real quick and I can say,
hold on a second and while I'm on the phone with you,
I can go on a website or Google.
I can't do that with,
uh,
with Verizon.
That sucks.
Yeah.
The only time you can do that I think is with the four g.
That's a,
I think that the four g's.
Lao,
is that True Brian?
Or does it not yet?
I'm sorry.
Four G for Verizon to do,
they allow you to make phone calls and access the Internet?
Um,
some of the devices I think does four g but only on four G.
Right?
The iPhone,
right.
Yeah.
The iPhone is always a step behind.
It was a step behind for the longest time.
It was three g before it's four g.
But you used to have to pay something.
It used to cost if you want to get off the iPhone tit,
like if you want it.
Like I told you,
I got an old android.
Oh,
I had that piece of shit for one day and I was like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
It was so clunky and shitty compared to my iPhone.
It wasn't even a question of whether or not I was going to deal with it.
It was just like,
you get the fuck Outta here with this.
I'm like,
this thing is dog shit immediate.
Oh,
it was so bad.
It was such a piece of shit.
Yeah,
it was terrible.
It was so bad.
But the new ones are dope.
They're like the galaxy s four is coming out March 14th isn't that supposed to
be the next level?
Shit.
Damn it.
Why didn't we get,
why even bother getting an android devices and now there's new ones coming out
on both apple and android.
I'm like,
oh,
I need to.
Especially Samsung,
they don't fuck around man.
They keep pumping out bad ass phones and they for the first time ever,
the galaxy s three outsold the iPhone or a factory worker.
The fucking photos on that thing.
Oh,
it's incredible.
In fucking balloon.
They're incredible.
The new ones are going to have ready for this.
A 13 motherfucking megapixel camera
and a phone.
The five facing cameras going to be two megapixels.
It's rear camera's going to be 13.
Jesus.
My billing,
I'm looking at my billing right now for Ting and I haven't really used my phone
much,
but like this month I used it a lot.
So my building's been $14 for one month,
$13 for another month,
and then this month it's going to be,
it looks like $25.
That's amazing.
Like I,
this month I've used megabytes.
I've used a 250 megabytes.
Does that my Wifi so much that I don't really use it.
I've seen some bills that have been crippling,
man.
Yeah.
You can fuck your life up with a cell phone.
Oh,
you sure can.
Especially if you,
you don't know your policy and you go over and you get hit with some overages or
travel and you don't really consider oh yeah.
International stuff.
Yeah.
International will crush you.
Go to rogan.ting.com savory stuff.
25 bucks.
All right.
You fucks also were brought to you by [inaudible] Dot com that's o.
N.
I.
T.
We've got a lot of cool shit and place a these days.
Not just,
uh,
the supplements that we've,
um,
been selling for a while.
But we also have steel maces and steel clubs that were selling.
We're trying to sell you the most gangster Shit available,
ladies and gentlemen,
including killer bee honey.
But now we have the steel clubs.
They're also referred to as club bells.
I use these all the time.
They're fucking awesome.
It's like a giant baseball bat,
like a wiffle bat member.
The fat wiffle bat that you would always try to grab because it was way better
than a regular wiffle ball bat.
Oh sure.
Big Fat ones where you could really,
that's what these are like,
but they're made of iron and your,
you do all these fucking crazy things called the shield cats with them and all
these exercises with it.
Persian guys do.
The Iranian guys and Indian guys,
a lot of Indian guys do it.
Friends.
Kids love you in the fucking new shit that we started selling at on it.
It's uh,
we,
we have kettle bells now.
Battle ropes.
We have an amazing kettle bell workout DVD.
It's the extreme kettlebell cardio DVD.
Um,
if you are going to do that though,
I would really suggest anybody that's interested in,
in doing kettle bells or any particularly or possibly dangerous exercise,
go and learn from a local guy.
Find a local guy who's a professional instructor and Kettle Valley.
It won't take much time.
He can show you the,
all the movements are fairly intuitive.
I'm sure a guy would let you videotape it,
you know,
and,
and he could give you just some tips to make sure that you don't hurt yourself.
You know,
I'm,
I'm going through some back issues right now myself.
Nothing like I can still kick box at 100%.
I could still lift weights but,
but I have some disc issues,
you know?
Oh sure.
And you know,
a lot of that,
you know,
it's just,
it's going to happen if you do something like Jujitsu.
But if you can avoid any kind of injury,
you really should.
Oh my God.
Anytime you can avoid any kind of injury you should.
And the best way to avoid an injury with kettlebells is to use proper form and
to learn from an instructor what kettle bells are.
If you've never seen them before,
it's a circular ball on the bottom,
like the bell.
It's made out of iron and it has a handle and it's a fic iron handle.
And what you do with these things is you swing them around and you use your
whole body to pick them up and it really engages your core and your legs and
your arms in like really weird functional ways that help you like in real life,
whether it's in athletics or whether it's in like just picking something up,
the ability to pick something up and move it around your house,
you'll have more strength of your whole body.
Like A,
I was hanging out with this dude really recently,
um,
who was a bodybuilder guy,
but he had like this little toothpick legs.
It's like,
it's so crazy because all he's doing is like doing bench press and curls does,
it makes you look good.
But then he's got these toothpicks that are holding all that up because he's not
using his whole body at the same time.
You see that at every gym.
By the way,
you see that guy who's so on athletic,
dangerous for your body because you could break shit like that.
That's when you blow hamstrings.
That's when you know you're,
you're,
you're designed wrong.
Absolutely.
Putting all that power up in your upper body.
Um,
I don't look sexy girls,
but you know what?
But you know,
the,
the main thing if you're going to start with kettle bells too is if you seek out
that local guy,
you're going to learn technique.
And even if you're already athletic,
what was that?
I don't know.
Sounds like a door shut.
Something happened here.
The feds.
Did you hear about the for?
Well,
it's all,
sorry about that later.
Anyway,
listen.
Um,
i.com o n n,
I t a.
We met the,
uh,
the audit power lifter guy this weekend.
It was very nice guy.
It sucks when you talk about back issues,
you know,
you're getting old when it doesn't involve comic books.
Yeah,
that's actually a pretty good joke.
That's a good joke for nerds.
Are we about to get raided?
A big truck just stopped.
Um,
anyway,
go there.
Check out all the different supplements as well.
And if you use the code named Rogan,
you will save 10% off any of the supplements.
All right,
go check it out.
But listen,
if you were at the event,
the back of the kettle bells,
if you,
even if you're already athletic,
if you get somebody that shows you technically how to do even a small change,
like,
oh,
your hips are like this,
you should move him here.
It can really prevent an injury.
Yes.
And it's a lot of times,
even if you are like,
you've worked out a lot,
it's a thing that you haven't done before and you don't realize it until
somebody who knows what they're talking about.
Yeah,
it could.
You could find to do this.
Yeah.
You can find yourself doing any kind of weightlifting,
any,
any kind of exercise.
Really.
Um,
so gay self in shape,
bitch,
use code name,
Rogan.
Save yourself some money.
All right,
Brian.
Red Band.
Chew the Music Thompson Jurors here.
We're fixing to be crazy.
The Joe Rogan experience,
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
We're full Tommy bonds.
Yo,
Tami,
please tell me about white girls with cornrows.
Very dangerous.
That's the cover.
That's the name of your,
uh,
your latest CD,
right?
Well,
yeah,
yeah.
White.
Why white girls with cornrows?
Just a very,
I think of them as a very dangerous,
often overlooked segment of our society.
So what's a,
what's dangerous about,
I tried to clarify,
first of all,
for people that I don't mean like white girls that just got back from The
Bahamas.
I mean like white girls to live in Baltimore.
Curious downtown chicks.
Baltimore's sure it's real dude.
Yeah.
And Paul Tomorrow.
So rough and the d the d scary right now.
I just did three weeks in a row.
No,
I did,
uh,
Baltimore,
then Cleveland and then Detroit back to back to back.
I was like,
dude,
I'm doing like recovering cities of America places.
I'm not going.
Those are the three.
I,
you know,
I did Ann Arbor and I felt like I was in a satellite colony outside of the death
star.
I felt like I was,
I was hanging out on like,
like some colony of white people try to keep it together.
Well,
there's state implodes around them.
There is a 47% illiteracy rate in Chicago now or any serious Detroit right now.
Detroit is the one that leaves the biggest impact for me.
Yeah.
Uh,
when you drive through it.
Oh,
Baltimore's funny because Baltimore,
they're like,
it's all these rows where literally block to block the everything changes when
you're in the city.
Yeah.
So they're like,
no,
these right here.
This is a really good neighborhood.
These are families now you see that next street right there.
You don't want to fuck around on that street.
Yeah.
That one right there.
And they're like,
yeah,
that's a bad neighborhood.
That's your neighborhood man.
No,
no.
That's a whole different neighborhood right there.
We saw that in DC.
Oh yeah.
We were talking,
I went to DC with Ari and Ari grew up there.
Oh,
that's right.
He went the,
it's where he first,
uh,
was uh,
he was doing stand up at the Improv there too.
Um,
when we went down the street as we're driving,
we're in this terrible neighborhood.
I mean it's really bad.
It's just like liquor stores,
people hanging out half naked on a corner.
It's just,
it looked like it was real sketch and then two blocks over there's Volvos
and shiny white people climbing out with your baby carriages.
I'm like,
Whoa,
what the fuck is this?
This is crazy.
It was downtown La.
Nah,
it was,
it was way more extreme.
It's way more extreme on the east coast.
The east coast has a completely different sense of like integration.
There's integration in like New York City,
but you just don't get in Los Angeles because nobody walks.
Right.
You know?
So I think you live on top of each other.
Living on top of each other is standard being on top of it or the being around
people of all sorts of races,
nationalities,
origins of to be around them all the time like you are in New York.
I think it leads people to be more open to the idea of being around people that
aren't in their same economic group to being closer to them.
Definitely.
Whereas like in la,
everybody's like,
get me the fuck out of this neighborhood.
Like,
you know,
you don't want to like,
like have a nice place in the hood that is not even in the question.
No,
no,
no.
You know,
and Ellie's really sliced and diced where you know exactly where everything is.
Like my dad's this neighborhood,
this is this kind of,
yeah,
it's very obvious.
There's no integration.
My friend Mo lives in Bedstuy in Brooklyn.
He's a white guy.
I really,
yeah,
I could,
why do you live in bed Stuy?
That's where Mike Tyson grew up and talks about crazy.
It was,
he goes,
well,
you know,
they've cleaned it up quite a bit,
it goes a,
nobody bothers us.
And uh,
you know,
I would rather live in a place like that and be able to afford an apartment.
I can move around and then live in a box and,
and,
and the city.
Wow.
I guess it's like,
that's one of the reasons why a lot of these neighborhoods have gotten better.
You know,
the idea of gentrification,
the idea of like,
and that's happened over and over again in New York when they realize,
hey look,
we've got a bad neighborhood,
but it's just a neighborhood that's got a bunch of shitty places.
If we buy those shitty places and start building nice places,
then it's a good neighborhood.
Yeah.
And then it's worth a lot of fucking money and it can happen like that.
It's happened on the east side of La.
Yeah.
A lot more.
Los Filez silver lake.
Yeah.
The area that used to be an area that like white people didn't really just fuck
around in at all.
You know,
it's uh,
and then it's like a good artist area.
But I'm saying like 20 years ago,
like most,
you know,
it was,
it was a lot of,
it was much more Latin population and then now it's like,
uh,
you know,
hipster community sliced and diced with a little bit of the Latinos that were
there predominantly.
So it's become like one bad motherfucker hipster move in and you know,
I have to imagine it's the same scenario as your friend.
I imagine it's the same scenario.
I bet.
You know?
Whereas as one dude or a couple people were like,
well we can get this bigger place and just kind of,
you know,
less desirable part of town for really cheap and then over time that slowly
becomes a thing and then they've,
you know,
populated an area and it totally changed it.
Yeah.
It's kind of crazy.
It's really,
that'd be crazy.
That happened in bedstuy though.
Oh B
it could easily happen because so many people spilling over from Manhattan.
Yeah.
There's so much money mean it's like a slow creep of money.
You know?
Those prices are insane.
Oh,
it's amazing.
Yeah.
Like you look at some of the apartments that are for sale and you like,
they're like $4 million and it's like a $1,200 Burbank apart.
It's so nuts,
man.
It's so crazy.
I stayed in an apartment in midtown that was 4,600 a month,
4,600 a month.
Oh my God.
The Guy was playing rank.
Nice.
Two bedroom.
Uh,
not,
not particularly.
Like,
like,
you know,
wow.
But Nice.
Like where you go,
right?
Yeah.
You have a nice apartment,
right?
Never.
And you're in my mind,
was it going to be 4,600 that's a crazy mortgage.
That's a mortgage for $1 million house.
And I told the guy,
I go,
don't you think you could get like $1 million house?
He was like,
yeah,
I'm going to do that sometime.
I was like,
whoa.
Wow Man.
Yeah,
but people love the people that
love living there.
Love live in there so much.
Yeah.
My,
my friend Jeff,
he fucking,
he would never live anywhere else.
He comes here like every now and again,
he's got a place here.
He'll come here,
but when he's,
when he's here,
he's like,
get me back.
And he gets back.
He was like,
this is where I love it.
I love it here.
He loves the city being in there.
I can see that you fall in love with that city though.
It's,
you know,
a lot of people love it,
man.
A lot of people love it.
For a lot of people.
It's like that,
that idea of having everybody packed in together,
they feel happy.
Yeah.
You know,
there's really is something like always going on.
Yeah.
Oh yes.
And I don't mean just like an activity,
a party like just being on the standing on a corner.
The street feels alive.
Yeah.
There's just always,
you know,
there's action.
People are remarkably cool in New York when you consider how big that's it is.
Yeah.
I mean they're remarkably cool.
Like people talk about how people are rude and the east coast like that.
Not that rude.
And I,
I think New Yorkers are particularly friendly actually.
I mean they're a little less tolerant of idiots,
but I think that the intelligence level that the average intelligence level of
people in the city,
it's like a little higher.
I tell him it's higher than Los Angeles.
Like you,
you,
the odds of you meeting a guy not knowing him very well and having a good
conversation with them.
Like,
say if you're in a waiting room and he strike up a conversation and it being a
really interesting conversation and the odds are way better in New York than
they are in La.
Great.
Great observation.
And 1000% agree.
And not only that,
I feel like La has a way higher sketch ball factor.
Oh look at this fucking guy.
Not like total hose artists.
Yeah.
You're going to roofie some chick just way high bullshit meters off the chain
here.
But you kind of go like,
Nah.
Yeah.
And actually in New York you see some guy who might be like eccentric,
kind of weird as shit looking,
but then he's like a super intelligent guy that you can have a great
conversation.
Yeah.
It's super possible.
And I mean not that you have,
not that you would really use it if you were there,
but you have access if you're in New York to the all those museums.
Yeah.
Just that alone,
having all that stuff right there.
I mean you're,
you're dealing with,
there's so many great museums.
Oh yeah.
There's so much cool shit to see.
And there's a Neil Tyson's place.
The,
uh,
what,
what does that a astronomy place Brian,
but they have that huge place that he's the one at Griffith Park.
Is that it is the Griffin?
No,
he doesn't do the Griffith Park Observatory.
That's out here.
He does something.
I was watching part of that podcast you did with this awesome.
You know,
it's really fun to watch as somebody who's just vocabulary is,
you know,
there's so our ticket,
yeah.
It's actually fun to listen to them speak because they speak so richly.
Yeah.
So clearly I was like listening to him speak and then missing what he was
saying.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like he kinda hypnotizes you in a way.
He has a beautiful voice.
He's a beautiful man.
He has a beautiful man,
but he's his what's,
there's something to be said about the tonal quality of someone's voice and
their ability to understand what they sound like.
And a lot of people don't know that.
A lot of people who are super obnoxious and come off really fucking bad.
One of the reasons why they come off bad,
it's like they're not registering that their intent is not being accurately
displayed by the way the communicate it.
Yeah.
There's like an the sounds that people don't like hearing this sharpness that's
necessary.
The misunderstandings a lot with what you're saying.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Well,
what he does so well is he knows how,
first of all,
he's got a beautiful voice.
He knows how to use the voice,
and he's got an immense vocabulary.
He's got an immense amount of knowledge when it comes to the cosmos and you
know,
and most of the stuff he's saying,
you've never heard it before,
but he knows it intimately and he's super passionate about it.
Right.
So it's like got a sense of theater to it,
but it's also an insane information.
Like he was telling us information about the,
the actual possible size of the universe.
And it just,
it just makes you,
it just makes you want to just not say anything for like 10 minutes and just go,
what?
Yeah.
Jesus.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
Those guys are so important because science so often is dry to kids.
Like a lot of kids think that science is like,
you know the idea of studying stars like Eh,
it's,
it seems like doll and this is serious five,
this is,
this is a but but blah blah blah.
The orbiter went around,
they don't have this like engaging like contagious passion that he has and when
kids hear him talk,
they get super pumped up about it.
You know,
as they should imagine if he were your teacher and like school and like I
wouldn't probably,
I would have probably never been a comedian.
Yeah,
I know.
I would've probably tried to be a scientist or something.
I would have tried to be an astronomer.
I forgot.
Like that was my teacher.
He would have been my hero.
You know what I mean?
You know,
to,
to like the,
the average fucking kid.
It's like constantly searching for someone that represents who they'd like to be
when they get older.
You know?
Because if you're around,
even if you love your dad,
you know,
you're around your dad all the time.
There's most likely a dad's and knucklehead,
you know,
your dad was born 1940 whatever it is for they're fucking idiots right from a
different time.
And so then you go to school and who you're dealing with,
school,
you punch.
People don't really want that job.
They just can't do anything else.
And most of them are really miserable in their personal life.
And if you knew them today as a grown adult,
you would think there were fools.
Yeah.
But back then there the figures of authority.
So it puts this sort of helpless feeling to you because you know their tools.
Yeah.
You know there are tools and you know,
they're teaching you and you know,
this is nonsense.
They don't,
they're not into this at all and they don't want to be here.
And that's the majority of the teaching experiences that I had.
The of being taught being class.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
It was a few standout guys who was a guy named Greg,
who was a Spanish teacher,
was really cool.
But Greg wound up bang and the 17 year old hall law.
Really if it was legal or not.
I remember Mr Keener's breath
fifth grade,
if you had Neil Tyson.
Yeah.
For uh,
a professor,
you'd be,
you'd be a fucking scientist.
Totally.
You were trying to do something in that world for sure.
That world man,
when those guys landed the rover on Mars and started screaming and cheering when
the pictures started coming up,
yeah.
You realize like how exciting.
That must have been fun again,
it's so,
because the idea that they were embracing was so crazy that stream and you had
so many detractors and you get people,
you would say that too.
And they were like,
are you fucking stupid?
Like smart people would say that to you.
They're talking about sending people to Mars,
you know,
and they're talking about,
uh,
you know,
right.
There's even a new thing about,
uh,
whether or not they should send couples because they probably won't ever be able
to come back.
Okay,
dude.
Now imagine that.
Imagine for a second if they pulled that off,
what our reaction would be watching that.
Like if,
if,
if they landed and they were like,
oh,
we're on Mars,
it's fucking awesome here.
You guys,
we would be like,
oh my God,
what did he say
back to
rescue us?
It takes six
some months to get there.
Oh my God.
What if they didn't know?
But that there's a constant
wow.
Back Mars.
Nobody recorded any sound and I don't realize it until they open the hatch.
This the planet makes us sound shit.
Oh Shit.
Pick you up.
It's going to be awhile.
And we're just smell like pussy,
pussy,
rats.
The,
they can't pick you up at all.
They can't get you.
They can send more people to hug you and give you your plugs.
She can't,
they can't send,
they can't send you back there.
The first trips they believe with people are going to be one way trips.
Really?
Yes.
But how would you drop them?
What would you leave them with?
W with enough to live with what?
You know,
um,
you got to get one of them,
boy scout knives.
They'd have like a bunch of different things.
So it's a spoon and a magnifying glass.
And you guys can make it three weeks and they're like,
what,
three weeks?
Oh Man.
Fuck that.
No it's not.
It can't be cool enough.
There's no way.
I mean the idea of being the first person on Mars,
I'm sure it's going to be appealing to a lot of people,
but not to me,
man.
To me,
I'd be like,
listen,
I'm not living in some fucking movie.
Okay,
you,
you're not,
I'm not going to be the first guy on Mars pitch.
Are you phrasing?
Do you know how bad Mars could suck?
Do you know back inside?
Do you want to live in Antarctica?
I don't want to live in New York,
but living in Antarctica,
I mean you,
you might as well be living at arc if you leave it on fucking Mars,
might as well.
Yeah,
that's,
that's not desirable least man.
Cause I'm pretty sure you're going to have to,
you know,
you're going to have to wear a mask everywhere you go.
You're going to home or they're going to have to put a dome over that bitch of
course.
And do you realize,
I'm like how unpredictable the entire thing from they get like shit.
They're like,
we thought it was going to be like this.
They're gonna be like,
yeah,
that's not really saying rocks and they hurt like everything that you thought it
could be way,
way off,
man.
Not only that,
right
bet Mars gets more fucking asteroids.
I bet they get more impacts because Mars is,
I'm,
I hope I'm not wrong about this,
but as it's been explained to me,
there's something called boats law and bodes law represents,
it's a way of measuring by gravity and mass.
When you get a series of planets,
when you measure the mass of one,
you can accurately predict how far away the next plan should be and apparently
the asteroid belt between Mars and Jupiter is the only thing wrong with boats
law in this source system.
As explained,
explained to me,
I might be wrong,
but that there's so many asteroids close to Mars and Jupiter that most likely
the idea is that either that's leftover shit from the formation of galaxies or
it could be leftover from an impact like earth one and earth to Earth at one
point in time was hit by another planet.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
That's like the main stream,
uh,
acceptance of how the moon was created.
And um,
the,
you know,
just the evolution of the earth itself.
And so it was at one point in time,
we were actually hit by a planet.
Imagine how dude hit by a planet.
We got hit by a planet.
So we basically became an enormous ball of lava.
Yeah.
So like,
who knows how long before everything cooled off.
I mean,
do you know,
who knows how many thousands of fucking years everything burned have to get hit
by a planet?
Plus a giant chunk of us came flying off and became the moon.
Yeah.
That's the whole idea of it all.
It seems it's,
it's two fantastic.
Well,
you know,
it's just as fantastic.
It is.
A planet floating above us every day.
Every day we go outside in broad daylight.
You can see the Moon in California because you know,
I know you poor folks in Columbus get cloudy skies all throughout the winter.
Um,
Cincinnati was the same way this weekend,
but you come back to La,
you can see the moon in the middle of day.
You'll see it fat and juicy just sitting up in the sky.
It looks all beautiful and the blue sky,
it's a floating planet and you're looking at it with your eyes and it's a
quarter of the size of the earth and it's right there.
Yeah,
it's floating in the air above you.
Like that might be the nuttiest shit you ever get to look at and you're just
like,
ah,
whatever.
I'm waiting for Ufo.
The UFO ain't nearly as crazy as the fact that there's a fucking planet floating
in the air.
Yeah,
you can see it.
You just got to make sense for real.
Like a teacher.
You're like that guy.
The moon is enormous,
man.
The moon is really big for food.
We take it for granted how cool it is.
See it.
Well,
you see the same side to,
it doesn't even spin.
It rotates around us.
The moon is a trip,
man.
The moon's that trip and so many ways because they say that if a moon wasn't as
big as it is,
our gravity or our,
um,
atmosphere wouldn't be a stable,
like our,
we wouldn't,
our,
um,
orbit wouldn't be a stable.
And what stabilizes us is we have this massive objects sitting there with us.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
That's nuts.
Like an ordered liberty literally to have this kind of life that,
and people are like,
wow,
they're going to do,
it'd be no life.
No,
it just wouldn't be this kind of life.
Life with figures shit out for sure.
Life figure shit out.
You know?
I'm just amazed that no one's ever figured shit out in the ocean.
And it's,
there's so much of it,
man.
It's a big,
but like life never figured shit out in the ocean.
Oh right.
Life in the ocean still lives like a fish.
You know?
Could you imagine if like we're running around on earth claiming to be super
smart,
but we're still running around killing things with her face.
Yeah.
We would say like,
how are we any better than than regular monkeys?
We're not.
Oh,
we are.
Because we have a language.
Those poor dolphins,
those poor fucks and killer whales,
they live in like regular fish.
They don't have condos.
It's true of the car.
They didn't have TVs and everybody's like,
oh,
they're just as smartest people.
The fuck they are the fuck they are.
Stop it.
They're not creating anything.
Yeah.
They could just make noise with their face and catch fish.
Just bigger fish.
Yeah,
they did pig there.
You know they're animals.
They've taken the air through a poll,
but basically they live like a fish.
There's not much difference between the killer whale on the tuna,
you know?
As far as like how the forced to live,
you've got to go get yours is no supermarket,
no credit cards.
They live like savages.
They live.
Yeah,
they are.
They're just like the bottom feeding fish.
Really?
Yeah.
They're ridiculous.
They're scrubs man scrubs the of the universe and killer killer whale scrubs.
Imagine if there really was intelligent life in something figured out.
I mean it doesn't seem,
it seems to me that if a monkey can figure out how to be conscious and how to be
a intelligent
here,
that a fish could figure out how to be conscious and intelligent down there and
develop a way to get up to the air world and wear like a a big water mask and
come and visit us.
They totally should,
but I think it doesn't happen because of there'll be just too much conflict.
When we started talking,
well he tried to open land parks.
Apparently you haven't seen creature from the black lagoon.
I have not.
This is what you ever see that you ever see that movie?
I watched that movie recently learned to read and so dope.
It's a Fishman Monster Fishman.
Pull it up.
Brian Reed creature from the black lagoon.
It's like a 1950s movie.
Really think.
Let me see.
Creature from the black lagoon.
I'm going to guess.
I'm going to guess I'm going to go with 1961 but um,
it's,
I'm probably off 1951 is it 51.
Okay.
It's 1954.
Really?
Wow.
It's a wow.
Okay.
Yeah,
so it's 1950s.
Wow.
I,
um,
remember this when I was a kid,
he was like one of my favorite monsters,
man.
Creature from the black hole was awesome.
It only got a 6.9 on the IMD.
Be What?
A bunch of cons.
I remember that was one of those myriad of 10 out of 10.
I'm sorry,
but if you're,
if you're talking about like old cool horror movies,
it's amazing.
It's a 10 that was one of those movies they played in the 80s with the three d
glasses where you would go to the grocery store and get those glasses and then
the red and blue glasses and they made it three d movie three days.
They changed it and made it three day to pull some of that up.
It's awesome.
It's looking at it,
the creature from the black lagoon.
Wow.
Yeah.
There's no explanation.
That's just where he lived.
Where did he come from?
Did he interact with people from science to haunt them?
Oh yeah.
He kidnapped bitches.
Oh really?
I snatch pitches up,
took them back to this case.
He's trying to make a more person person thing.
I got you.
I knew it'd be a person hybrid,
like he's a person fish hybrid.
He's like,
I had to take the shit to the next generation and that it's just me as a hybrid.
Fuck some white bitch.
He definitely looks like a child.
Made them in the image that I saw.
Well back then,
man,
that was for fish it for,
that's an amazing outfit,
you know?
Yeah.
He's got some pretty eccentric gear.
Those guys had a struggle,
you know,
it was hard to do special effects and the 1950s you know,
did you ever see like even stuff and now that you see from the eighties you're
like,
yes,
this is embarrassing.
Is that the debt is the merch and mystery
of a hundred million years ago
up from the depths of unknown waters
comes a creature to confound science
and terrorize.
No.
Wow.
These are awesome.
Yeah,
he's got web fingers and claws and shit.
Creature from the black lagoon and it's all black and white and awesome.
Shocking,
shocking in the stark realism.
Look at it when you make that up.
Perfected three dimension is black and white,
but it was three D.
Isn't that fascinating?
Look how weak that dude looks.
It looks back then,
didn't know nothing about bench press then.
I didn't know nothing about Kettlebell.
He had no shroom tech sport and life creatine going through his system.
Those dudes didn't know deadlifts.
Absolutely.
They'll like that.
Don't like their leading men back there like a joke with their shirts off and
you ever done a hack squat?
You compare it to like the rock.
Yeah,
no.
Right.
Oh fuck.
Oh my God.
Hot.
It never worked out.
A day in her life with a billion eggs inside of her.
You come anywhere near eggs,
leap down,
grab the sperm and crawl back in.
Yeah.
All the guys back then were,
they almost look like they were all gay maybe at work cause they were all like,
you know,
do they all had body here?
Which dudes all shave today?
It's really interesting when you just see what happened.
Groom was,
well I think giveaway a lot in this movie gets lit on fire and falls in the
water.
Look at that dude.
I'll study with his shirt off.
Oh
whoa.
Just jumps in the water.
Took Rita out.
Damn
deep.
Deep,
This is awesome.
Into the waters of his domain,
so he just drown and may follow.
He just drowned a bitch.
Yeah,
I guess he's like drowning her.
I Dunno what's happened during the middle of a gator roll.
They're amazing.
Three dimension creature from the black lagoon.
Oh Man.
Isn't in the fascinating thing when you can go back and back in
time like that and see something and see what,
what media looked like in 1954 oh my God.
I know.
And then that you know that people would see certain things.
It'd be so captivated.
Valid.
We would fucking love that movie if we lived in 1954 yeah.
Well actually what do we as adults,
what would it be so psyched?
I think so.
Because you had never seen shit like that.
You might even be more impressed.
Like,
what the fuck?
How did they do this?
But I was thinking like,
who goes to sales movie?
Would it be kids?
Because in 1954,
guys our age are almost dead.
Yeah,
that's true.
I had a late thirties.
Like,
who are you?
You're not even alive.
But they're also,
they're also more like scared of,
um,
the unknown of the unknown.
But I think that would be a thing where they'd be like,
Oh,
you're not,
you don't want to bring a kid do something like this.
This is an adults only kind of rated r mean Appdex.
This white woman takes her to the bottom of the ocean.
He's scary,
real scary.
And he's,
you don't take a white bitch into the bottom of the ocean unless you in either
killer or fucker.
Yeah.
He's probably doing about fair.
You're probably going to kill her unless you can come really quick.
She's going to drown.
It's rude.
Yeah,
there's definitely,
there's a lot of stuff you don't want to see in this goal.
1954.
The audience wasn't ready.
Do you know the creature was modeled after the Oscar real?
Yeah.
Well,
they figured with a fucking plot like this were a shoe it,
how could we go wrong?
Guys were dealing with a Gil man.
He's a monster that kidnaps and then fucks and we got hot white benches that he
kidnaps.
This movie's going to be big water.
He drowns them,
he rapes them and then he leaves them back to the surface in real black and
white.
Three it's going to be amazing.
Three d black and white.
That's going to be amazing.
Holy Shit.
There's no better piece of evidence about how our society has changed.
I think then watching our old shows and movies like try to watch father knows
best.
It's beautiful.
It's like you're watching a comedy like you,
you watch father knows best and it's so awkward and like clunky and fake and
like not in any way resembling how human beings really behaved.
It becomes a comedy.
Yeah.
Like you may guess it was supposed to be a comedy back then,
but it wasn't.
It wasn't.
It was a drama,
comedy,
drama.
What would you call it?
It was like a comedy,
right?
Yeah.
It's funny for being sucky.
It's funny for being really stupid.
Well father knows best and it was fucking stupid pipe.
It's like the whole thing is like so weird.
Oh,
it's crazy.
Surreal.
If you watch like see if you could pull up a father knows,
you know it's also really bad that like shows you like,
it makes you think about what were,
what were you thinking when we saw this and where people impressed are like uh,
music videos.
If you watch old music videos and you're like,
Holy Shit,
this is,
oh yeah,
but at the time you know that they're like,
do you see this guy?
He can make his face freeze on the screen and then they'll leave it there for a
minute and a half while some other shit goes on behind it.
And that was like they were showing off the technology when they made those,
but they weren't even like making it.
They were like,
just look at the buttons we got with this new software.
Like the videos were just bad,
new special effects.
Here's some of black guys never said,
hey man,
you check out that contract.
Google video.
No one's ever said it.
I've never heard say that ever.
Yeah.
Some of those old videos were fucking preposterous.
Terry,
you know what I heard the other day for a long time that I haven't heard in a
long time.
That really brought me back.
That I want candy song.
Really hot bitch.
What are you laughing about?
You hear that?
I like a strip club.
No.
Was that Chippendale's?
Constantly.
That's a,
that's a girl song.
Girls singing about a boy.
Um,
I think I was at a restaurant and it was playing in the background.
I was like a pizza place or something and it was like Whoa.
Immediately put you in a good mood.
Well I just always,
the girl
was the sheriff.
Did you?
Did you have that sound?
I'll do that stupid shit.
Fuck.
How old do you think on this?
Terrible.
Shut up.
It's so bad.
Breaking my brain is so god damn bed.
God.
Well,
you know it's almost just as bad.
Ah,
yes dear.
You ever see that Sitcom?
Yeah.
Might as well be the same fucking show.
There's a lot of sitcoms that are on even currently that are like,
Holy Shit.
They've been shown a yes,
dear marathon,
500 Nickelodeon.
Yeah.
It's unfucking believable.
How bad that show.
Oh,
it's madness.
Yeah,
like you're watching madness.
I always wondered why isn't he Clark blew a fuse?
Like what happened?
Yeah,
I bet it was just working on that shitty show over and over and over again.
Those goddamn scripts every to it's like,
cool,
I'll pull a boob.
I'd been working at the same plant.
Yeah,
I dunno.
There's something w extra bad about being a comedian and being on an unfunny
show.
It's just knowing how bad it is.
Yeah.
There's something extra bad.
That's a fucking show.
I was watching on the family the other day.
That is the best show.
So good chicken.
Do you remember how racist he was?
Look at it.
This works for you and Henry.
You're trying to find somebody else.
You don't call that crooked?
No.
You walking off by number one.
Where does that place?
Henry Jackson.
It was of a joke.
Why is he number two?
Because me,
dad,
they can only be one.
Number one I want to know,
be chill.
I like Mae Jemison number two long before I come along I suppose,
but the Puerto Ricans a number three then this just showing it that a little
gallery,
your point of weakness could be fun.
Be Judging your change can be three,
three,
a three B.
It was the greatest shot.
He couldn't make that show.
Now I need to get the,
show me how good it is.
Yeah.
I wonder if they even censored the DVDs because I mean he used,
oh he dropped in bombs.
He called everyone shakes in it.
We've become a bunch of pussies.
Yeah.
We've become super duper sensitive pussies and you know a lot of people
apologizing for a lot of shit because of that you'll,
you'll lose out on comedy,
you know,
because you're not,
you can't tell me those guys don't still exist.
Oh yeah.
No,
you can't tell me that racism doesn't still exist.
It absolutely does.
But I think racism in the context of a show,
like all in the family,
the way he's ready,
I think it helps people.
I think it helps people relate to it.
Like how he's such a moron and it makes you realize he's a fucking idiot.
Yeah.
It makes you relate to how everybody else sees him.
It's like it's probably good for the culture.
Absolutely realistic about a guy like that.
And you even see in that character because it's so deep,
you actually see how it's not the only thing that defines him.
So you still have a soft spot in a way for this guy who has the detestable
aspects of his personality.
He also did,
I mean Carol O'Connor,
so who to play them did an amazing job.
A plane.
My God,
amazing job because he was a guy that clearly loved his children,
who wasn't a terrible person.
Right.
You know,
he was tolerant even with meathead living with him and never got violent or
anything like that.
You know what I mean?
You can think about how a lot of fathers would have been like way more horror,
but it was like he also was a buffoon and that buffoonery sorta look,
you go,
oh,
that's why he's racist.
The same reason why he's the butt of all these jokes cause he's a buffoon and I
think that's a good thing.
I don't think that's a bad thing at all.
But you,
you're right.
You could.
We don't have that today.
The thing is when you cut,
you don't want to carry,
they would censor a character like that.
Today you're doing a disservice to just your own honesty about people because
you're not acknowledging that.
Like you said,
that person's out there.
Yeah.
It's like how come you can acknowledge that the murderers are out there?
How can you can acknowledge every week on CSI that there's a crazy fucking
serial killer chopping up hookers.
You can do that every week and nobody has a problem with it.
But if they had one character on TV that was a racist white guy that was talking
shit about the chinks in the specs and it'd be like,
what the fuck?
Everybody would protest.
People would say they were going to boycott at Internet marketing campaigns a
stop the hate.
And when his comedy too far,
well,
you know,
now did you see on the Superbowl the commercial that that people,
they didn't want it run because of the white guy do in the Jamaican accident.
Like that was the guy,
they sent out a press release about how offensive it was.
And um,
it was,
it was a car commercial where like the guy in Minnesota,
a white guy,
he's doing a bad or not even bad,
it,
I think it's pretty decent Jamaican accent,
uh,
throughout the commercial.
It's so crazy that they wanted an apology and then you have,
uh,
at another end of that,
what does it JC penny is trying to get,
was trying to get,
or Sears,
um,
has,
uh,
Ellen's generous as a spokeswoman and then there's protesters.
They're like,
we don't want,
you just lost a dollar for hiring her.
You know,
they weren't good and we don't want your flooring dollar.
And they would get more people supporting them wherever they're going to lose
for those people that are not going to get back unless they stand up for it.
Yeah.
And then talk about a fucking stupid,
that's what do you watching Brian?
That's the commercial.
He wasn't just talking about,
oh look how look this is what they,
these people wanted.
And uh,
this commercial polled
golf,
then miss the gym.
Giulia,
turn the frown the other way around.
Hey Dave,
you're from Minnesota,
right?
Yes.
I 10,000 lakes.
The gopher state.
So in conclusion,
things are pretty dismal.
You know what?
This room needs a smile.
Who want to come with Di traveling
by car.
Why
Dave?
Really for real.
They pulled that.
No they did not.
They wanted to,
a group one brought,
they were like,
this is the racist.
Awful.
Oh my God.
Prejudice commercial.
My God.
And you need to pull this shit down.
That's hilarious.
So what was the name of the group that wanted to pull it?
If you did a Google search for it?
Uh,
the Superbowl,
Jamaican,
Minnesota and commercial.
Uh,
you'll see.
Yeah,
it was a whole thing.
And then,
and then everybody was anticipating because that new story came out before the
Superbowl.
Like,
wait til you see this shit like protest where they then that aired,
you know like a,
yeah,
that's what we're offended by now.
People are really
so selling.
Meanwhile they were really clever and how they did that where everything the guy
says it is very positive.
Yeah.
It's not like,
you know,
doing a,
a Jamaican accent but just like bang it a bunch of bitches and sleeping in a
closet.
Yeah,
yeah.
Stealing orange juice or something,
you know?
He was like trying to make everybody smarter.
I'm a Jamaican pot smoking rapist.
You guys
all right enough with that.
People are so fucking sensitive.
They're so stupid.
Someone,
someone wrote some blog about what's his face that did the Oscars?
Stephan quo.
Oh yeah.
Apparently said something about,
nobody can understand sound behind but,
but no one cares because she's so hot.
It's kind of funny.
You know what I mean?
It's not offensive.
Oh,
come.
And this fucking chick wrote this article where it was like,
so what you're basically saying is that her opinion is invalid.
It doesn't matter if she's communicating because you find her attractive and you
can't understand it because she's Hispanic.
Like w w what you're,
it's a comedy joke.
It's a joke.
You fuckhead you got damped supersensitive shit.
Fuck.
It's the worst that is ruining,
that's ruining the fun and it's ruining life.
And,
and just,
uh,
it,
it's,
it's going to ruin communication between people.
Is that type of reaction did you see with a,
like what Espn,
uh,
they issued an apology on behalf of Brent Musburger for the national
championship game when he commented on Aging Mclaren's girlfriend and just like,
yes.
And you watch him like he has,
you want him to apologize.
She said she was pretty,
like when you put a woman,
uh,
you,
you starting quarterbacks get all the,
like the beautiful ones.
And then I bet there's a lot of young boys out there in Alabama right now that
just started throwing the ball around,
just warming their arm up,
getting ready,
you know?
Yeah.
What's wrong with that?
It's he,
I mean,
the implication is that she is only with him because he's who he is and that,
that he only sees in her beauty because that's all Brent Musburger talked about
was how beautiful she was.
And you know how she's not just a piece of meat and people wrote articles and
had their opinions about how unbelievably offended they were.
That Brent Musburger was like,
wow,
what a beautiful woman to this obviously gorgeous woman that is standing there
that anybody's reaction would be,
wow,
what a beautiful woman.
She is.
Not like,
wow,
I wonder what her thoughts are right now.
It's so hilarious.
People are so silly and the real problem is,
and other people,
but listening to them,
that's the real problem.
Of course,
you know,
it's a real problem is that they can,
they can protest and they don't get mocked the way they would in your house,
the way they would in your neighborhood,
the way they would in a normal,
healthy community.
Someone brought that up.
He'd be like,
shut him the fuck out of here.
He crazy asshole.
Right.
But because of the fact that they know that they can,
you know,
could you imagine if like someone in your neighborhood was a,
a guy and he had a beautiful wife and you knew that he was a football player and
so we were all sitting around and you're like somewhere guys are warming their
arms up,
looking at her like,
can I get to be one of those?
You'd laugh at that guy.
He's silly.
You know what I mean?
Like
people are actually genuinely pretending to be upset.
Yeah.
We can't be actually upset.
You're upset at the world if you're upset at that,
you're not really yes.
Because you're really focusing on something that is,
it's even less than important.
Like it,
it doesn't even belong in that like circle of conversation.
This is not an issue.
You're wasting your time.
And we all know it.
That's why we get,
we get upset about it.
By that we know that you're wasting everybody's time to ask for apologies for
something that you might interpret coming out.
Like if it's not even a direct statement.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's,
it's a weird thing that's going on where we've been around for so long and
comedy in this offensive comedy has been around for so long.
But there's this new thing,
this righteous indignation that people were claiming now more than ever where
they're pretending that there's not a,
a joking context to a lot of this stuff that let that joking context doesn't
even exist.
Yeah,
it's joking.
Context doesn't exist and they'll take a joke as a statement.
Did you know that he said he would like to see the queen getting eaten out by a
hot 20 year old?
Cause I said that once I was talking about the queen.
I was like,
you know,
she's probably a nice old lady.
Well wouldn't it be great if she was a lesbian?
I mean wouldn't that be like,
cause if you,
if you know,
if you made now if someone just look at that,
oh Joe Rogan was hoping the Queen get eaten out by hot 20 year old.
You do you have a put that in the paper in England they would go crazy.
Like what are you saying?
Obviously,
I don't really mean that these are the jokes,
but t to cut out that aspect of communication is to pretend it's like you're
playing dumb.
Like you don't think so.
You might not think it's funny,
but you know the difference between someone jokes
around and a very casual joke around,
by the way about a girl being attractive and guys are warming up their arms,
throwing the ball around cause they'd like to have an attractive girlfriend.
Like are we pretending that we don't like attractive people?
Exactly.
Like what did we,
what did we mad at?
Or,
and we're also pretending that like if,
if you're factoring in and attractive persons attractive attraction level,
then that is a cheap and,
and shortsighted of you.
Like what about the other,
you know,
factors about this person,
but you're like,
well,
why are we going to pretend like they're level of attraction isn't a factor.
It's a real factor.
It's gonna.
It's gonna determine a lot of things in that person's life.
Right.
You know,
and we're going to just ignore that because they're attractive.
Yeah.
Yes.
Come on.
So stupid.
Just like ugly people don't have a good,
you know,
we can talk about that.
There's real,
it's fucking real.
It's a shit.
Roll the dice and you all know it.
Goddammit.
Trent Reznor his wife.
I just found out about her.
Look at her.
She is the most,
I found out about her music and then I was like,
well I need to find out who this is.
I need to stop soccer boy.
Yeah,
I need to stock her.
And then I found I was turning this resonance wife,
but her music is like pink Floyd mixed with electronic music.
It's really good.
I haven't read,
what's her name?
Her bed.
Her bands called how to destroy angels.
They have a new CD that just came out today.
That sounds like an angry bitch.
And then I tweeted,
I tweeted how much I like it.
And then all these people are look good.
She's the new Yoko Ono if she killed nine snails.
Huh.
Oh Wow.
This woman who wrote this article,
I kind of agree with some of the things she's saying though,
which her name is.
This is the one was complaining about,
uh,
went comedy does not win a free pass is the name of the article saying Seth
Macfarlane at the Oscars.
Okay.
Some of what she's saying I agree with,
you know she's saying she's sick of people saying things that are racist and
sexist and that someone saying it's just comedy somehow gives you a free pass.
It doesn't give you a free pass.
I agree.
I agree with that.
But you know,
it does give you a free pass if it's funny.
It's funny.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's what she's missing.
Like if someone says something fucked up and racist but hilarious.
Yeah,
you can say that.
You can say it,
you can say it as long as I know that you're just joking and there's this
certain shit like you'll do like yo like crack like this fucked up the half
smile and you'll say something and I know you're bullshitting.
You're,
you're like doing a joke to me and I know you're doing it and I'll laugh my ass
off because I know you really don't mean this mean thing that you're saying,
but you'll say it joking and like just say that smile.
It's like you can't quite,
it's fun.
It's a fun thing to do and it's not reality.
It's not like a statement on things.
The idea that joking doesn't exist or the idea that something that is fucking
hilarious shouldn't be said because it's also racist or it's also is that's so
silly.
I mean can I tell you too that I feel like the,
they're basically our two groups as far as who gets like your point,
what you're saying and then who gets upset by it and it's almost almost split
down the line of intelligent and not so intelligent that we're as intelligent
people.
I feel like get what you joking.
They get joking around that people who are a little bit,
you know,
and then that breaking it down to like an Iq level but they're like,
do you not get this right now?
I agree with you.
To a certain extent.
But I also think that there's one other segment that you have to address and
that is unhappy people.
That's very true.
There's a lot of smart people that are fucking miserable and they want to
complain about anything they can.
And anytime they think they have the red light or the green light to go,
they will just go,
right.
The country is shit.
They can fucking think up because they've been looking for a green light.
They've been looking for a chance to get pissed about something.
And if you say these x words in a row and they know that this is a green light,
I'm going after this fuck.
And I just find the angle,
what's the angle to attack him and how he believes slavery should be back in
season.
You believe what?
This per,
I cannot leave yet.
I just indignation.
And you know what?
You make a good point because the,
that can be either a smart or a dumb person that,
and they're,
and they're often smart,
often smart,
and that when they,
if they do get happy,
um,
you get to experience like,
uh,
whether they're smart or dumb,
I totally different person.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're more joyful.
And we have another problem with people that are really smart is that they
recognize the variables.
They recognize the consequences of failure.
They recognize the consequences of their own laziness or whatever it is that's
kept them from being successful.
They are frustrated by their own inability to reach their potential in life.
So then when they find a green light,
like it's Catholic fall and telling jokes,
the Oscars like they're frustrated.
Right,
okay.
Already and smart and go find something to attack when you're really sort of
projecting some,
some of your internal bullshit on it,
you know,
a silly subject.
Him saying that Salma Hayek is hot,
so no one cares that you can understand her.
That's what,
that's what's horrible about that.
Have you ever heard her talk,
Jesus fucking Christ and we pretended that she's easy to understand.
Are you really going to pretend that that's a good,
I don't know what the dual Mr Jaws.
Yeah.
She's fucking really hard to understand.
Yeah,
of course.
And she's also really hot as fuck.
Yeah.
I've met her in real life.
She's beautiful.
She's very,
very,
she was on that and here comes the boom movie.
She's beautiful.
She's smoking,
but why would it,
why would she be upset that she's hard to understand really?
If it didn't make sense,
it wouldn't be funny.
For the record,
I'd like to fill her up and seal her shut.
Yes.
On the height.
Yeah.
I would like to fill her up with so much come that she could float in the ocean.
She would just,
she would be,
she's so buoyant.
They don't even know why.
I would like her to have
so much common hurt that it's dripping out of her nose and she uses it as
seasoning on her talk.
And you know what?
This dummy that wrote this needs to understand,
here's the big part.
If it didn't make sense,
it wouldn't be funny.
Okay.
If you try to say that about Jennifer Aniston and nobody understands her,
but no one cares because she's so hot,
people would be like,
what?
Yeah.
What are you talking about?
Jennifer?
Aniston is very easy to understand,
right?
So why are you pretending?
Why are you saying that's hurtful?
That's crazy talk.
And you're talking about the Oscars silly expression of,
you know,
real rewarding people that are making movies and all you have to do this,
this guy,
he's just trying to get a couple of he,
he's in haws in between.
You know,
he's got a few moments to make a little bit of an impact.
Yeah.
Hey,
let's say Sammo high is hot and fucking again our standard,
but who cares?
Okay,
good,
good.
And then like your co constructing a little comedy routine.
Yeah.
You mentioned have a high pressure that hosting Gigis well you know what should
be high pressure writing this stupid blog shit out.
She's had a thousand people on reddit review this blog and then,
and then,
then decide,
you know how it gets raided.
We like red stars over the top of it.
Yeah.
And then you,
then this company decides whether or not they want to fucking print your dumb
shit.
Jesus.
But she's right about that comedian shouldn't get a free pass.
They shouldn't like their shit and it's just racist and it's not funny.
And you,
you hear it and it's not,
it's,
you know,
someone crossed the line.
And a lot of times that's an competence.
A lot of times it's guys who think that they're being edgy,
so that's funny.
But they don't really know how to be funny.
And like we've all worked with guys there are shockingly bad.
Oh yeah.
You know,
and that,
that sort of calm.
Sometimes people say things and they just say things because they're stuck on
stage and they start talking.
I didn't even know what the fuck they're saying,
but they're trying to be edgy.
Right.
So then they say something like really fucked up and race.
Have you ever seen that happen?
Yeah,
I was.
though that feeling when you're panicking.
But this obviously this is,
she's talking about a monologue,
but I've seen it with,
I'm very like a guy trying to make a very like,
uh,
like trying to be edgy in a sex joke and then just goes through it and you're
like,
Holy Shit.
Like you sound like you're going to murder and kill and rape bitches tonight.
Like you could tell he just didn't know.
You know,
he just wanted to run through it.
Yeah.
Crazy.
It sounded and you're like,
it does not sound good man.
There's,
there's no joke there.
Yeah.
There's certain certain things that people say on stage and the way they,
Sam,
one person,
you could say it and it's really hilarious.
And then like half the Shit Joey Diaz says,
if it wasn't someone as lovable as Joey Diaz,
you'd be like,
get this guy off.
If he was like an awkward white guy that was kind of shifting or if you just saw
his,
uh,
what he says written.
Yes.
You'd be like,
oh man.
Yeah,
you did.
You got to be,
while you'll never see that.
You don't have to worry about that happening.
That's not written anywhere.
That act,
they written down.
They got mad at me.
Once we're having a notebook,
what are you going to walk around with this fucking law book?
Really like you want it?
He's fucking,
what are those?
What's that?
What's that place that they all go to?
What's the alternative room used to be?
What are you one of those fucking UCB almost
notebook.
You know what the Fuck I'm saying?
You're letting everybody know you got your notebook.
It's my fucking nervous I can put to go on stage.
I don't know what to say to that.
I'm letting everybody know that I take notes like no fucking does that even mean
he's so great.
I've seen him a go on stage and just really just talk shit on people in the
audience for like 15 minutes.
Just talk things out and that there was nothing.
He was really just in the moment and it was like the funniest shit I've ever
seen.
Yeah,
he you,
you can't like personality and like what is funny and what's not fun.
It's also so subjective.
So someone saying a comedian getting a free pass.
Well,
it might not be good for you.
Okay.
But you got to understand that that's that person doing this thing.
It's like the same as someone singing a song.
You're just not thinking about it that way.
You know when someone is singing a song,
they're creating a piece of instrument entertainment.
When someone's doing a joke,
they're creating a piece of entertainment too,
but it's a completely different process and sometimes it doesn't work.
It's not like someone said that like you asked them,
Hey Thomson girl,
what do you think about white girls with cornrows?
And you know,
and you just go,
well,
you know,
I fucking think there are a bunch of crazy bitches.
They'll stab you.
Like you're not being interviewed for the news.
Right.
You're telling jokes,
of course.
And that that's a real like,
to me,
that's a real social problem that people need to be called on because I think
when people think that they can just get away with being twatty like that and
everybody gives him that political correct free pass and puts logic out the door
and doesn't call him on it going,
yeah,
that's not what's going on here.
This is,
well,
you shut the fuck up if I was in your living room,
can you imagine if you're in your,
in your house and you and a fucking Seth macfarlane are sitting there joking
around and he says that about Salma Hayek and you guys both start laughing.
He like a couple of,
you know,
a couple guys would,
and then this woman is also there and she's on the couch,
just the three of you.
And she starts complaining,
Oh yeah,
you'd be like,
what?
And then and,
and you would have a crazy,
a con argument about they're your size and then you'd be like,
we're never hanging out with that person ever again.
Well,
it's the most ironic thing because lefties and progressive people are always
espousing freedom of speech.
The First Amendment,
freedom of the press,
they're always talking about how important it is to have a free internet.
But meanwhile they're also like the first people willing to get at someone
expressing themselves in a manner that they find amusing or that they find,
you know,
they find shocking but funny.
You should have free speech up until it bothers me.
Yes,
exactly.
Free speech up until you cross the conservative line.
And then when I feel like you've crossed into some area where I can make fun of
you.
Do you ever get,
um,
have you gotten mail hate mail about jokes?
You know,
not really.
Yeah.
I mean sure.
There's been certain things that people have been upset about it.
Yeah.
I always feel like going like,
like do you remember this thing that you're up,
this was on a standup comedy show or this was a comedy?
Well you had a lot of people mad at you about that bike joke.
Right?
So many.
You looked like a little like bothered by it at one point in time.
Like I didn't know what to kill you.
What weather?
Like it was a normal reaction like cause it was the first thing that had gotten
any like real exposure
and everybody wants to kill you.
The big thing that it got was it got the um,
he got the Huffington post home comedy page for a day.
So like it was the first thing on huffpost comedy because it was using,
being used to promote your special season of actually,
well,
but my special in was that was the season debut of the series.
So it was hey the series is back for season,
whatever,
here's a clip from the first episode,
you know,
so it was that kind of thing,
like a big promo thing.
What's the series?
It was comedy central presents,
which is right.
So they were going to air,
you know,
15 of them.
How many did they do last year?
They did about,
I think around 16.
That's great.
Yeah.
That's called the half hour now.
They changed the name of it and then they just shot the new ones.
Uh,
yes.
This past weekend in New York did,
you should try to get one of those Brian.
Actually I should.
There should be a goal when I'm talking about buddy.
It should be your goal.
Your goal should be to put one of those together.
You can do that.
Hey get manager first or something.
Like get a notebook,
get a notebook.
Don't worry about that dude.
You don't need a manager first.
You need to just,
just
do a lot of writing.
We'll a lot of writing get on stage.
You know,
you got some really killer jokes.
Did you have some funny shit?
You have some good ideas like you could really like,
you can really like put down a special if you want it to,
if you really wanted to dedicate yourself to it.
Yeah.
Work up to that for sure.
Man.
Have you ever been so drunk that you can even like you had to just get off the
stage?
No,
never.
Never got drunk.
No,
no,
no.
I've,
I've been,
um,
I've really,
the most I've ever had is like a buzz from drinking where I recognized that it
was throwing off my timing and stuff like and then um,
I just couldn't think as quick.
That's not good.
So I I I personally,
I mean I know it,
everyone's different with it.
I don't drink until I'm done performing cause I will fuck me up sometimes.
I do.
Sometimes I have a couple of drinks and you pull it off.
Yeah.
But I,
I prefer honestly I prefer my sets,
uh,
when I'm just a little bit high
or sober.
Yeah.
Those are my best sets.
Yeah,
me too.
But every now and then I'll go up lit and crush.
Especially like at the Ice House,
Jesus Christ.
Cause it's like home base.
I'll get a couple of Jack Daniels and go up to the ice house because the ice
house is like so positive.
Great.
Like everyone,
there is all hugs.
The waiters are cool,
the bartenders are cool,
the waitresses are cool,
the managers are cool.
It's like when you go to the ice house,
it's like,
that's like a love.
That's like set a family environment.
When we do as Wednesday nights there,
we'll probably do one next week too.
By the way,
folks.
We do those Wednesday nights and it's packed on a Wednesday night at 10.
It's like you could do anything there.
So those are my get hammered from.
I could get a little fucked up.
That crowds shut there Friday.
By the way.
Do you wear at the little mouse who?
Yeah.
Who either with I believe,
I can't remember now.
I don't have to look at my phone.
Harmful advertise.
What time is your show?
That's at 10 o'clock ice house,
comedy.com desk squad show.
We have a very odd podcast on,
um,
on,
on Friday with a doctor Amit Goswami.
It's a theoretical physicist.
Wow.
Particle physicists.
Guys,
what's he going to talk about?
Theoretical physicists,
like they write a book or like is it's going to talk about the nature of matter.
He's going to talk about string theory.
He's going to talk about how the fucking world is really constructed inside of
every atom.
It's just empty space.
How this,
this idea of strings vibrating that control and,
and create all matter.
It's going to be a total mind fuck because he's like super legit.
He's,
you know,
he's like legit as those quantum scientists go,
those quantum guys are so strange.
It's so hard to understand because everything they're doing like is,
is all this alien mathematical language.
Like you see them writing it out and in,
in that alien mathematical language as they're writing down all those fucking
symbols and how that Einstein,
yeah.
You know,
fucking,
what's that movie with Matt Damon and uh,
Oh yeah.
What was that movie?
A bunch of numbers.
Um,
goodwill hunting.
Good will hunting.
Yeah.
When he's writing all that stuff on the board and you don't know if it's right,
you know,
you don't know if that shit's fucking no idea what all that is.
He might as well be right in nature and hieroglyphs shit for mathematics.
It's complex my flags.
But when he's writing that,
I'm like,
these guys are writing that shit.
Like I've seen them like on notes,
like they'll have an inspiration for the way and equation.
It's supposed to be interacting with the environment and like
my brain,
just like the real problem with didn't dealing with those guys.
It's like you're,
even when you're,
you're asking questions about how they came to the conclusions,
like how they understand these things and where were the ideas of string theory
come from?
It's like you can't even measure it.
Like they,
they're just,
they're talking about something that they say and like number form and it'll
show you like pate but you'll never get it.
No,
you're going to be like,
oh,
okay.
Like you'll try it again.
They spray pixie dust and then say Alica Zam and
babies are born.
I'm pretty sure I wouldn't get it because I don't get Algebra one.
I don't think I would get the advanced shit with it that I don't even,
I can't understand the beginning of what they're trying to even explain.
I think some people just don't have the capacity or the ability,
you know,
I think it's like almost anything.
If you have an interest in it and you pursue it,
yeah,
you're good at it.
And I think mathematics is probably real similar to whether it's literature or
even athletics is like,
what do you focus your energy on?
You focus your energy on this.
You're going to figure out how to do it.
If it's,
if it's interesting to you and you,
I mean you might not be the best in the world at it,
but if you put your focus on it,
you're going to be able to figure out how to do it.
That's true.
Almost anything,
almost anything.
But it's like what entices you?
Does it do you?
Are you,
are you like,
Ooh,
math,
no,
you're not with you.
It's like,
aw,
stage time when we could do a joke.
Yeah,
I'm going to kill.
That's like that's,
that's what entices you.
What's attractive to you is what you pursue.
What's attracted to you or attractive to you stand up comedy.
But if you were one of those wacky dudes like that Russian guy who solved this
prize,
that we're going to give them $1 million prize.
The guy who said he didn't even want the money.
He's so fucking crazy.
This dude is just up there in Siberia,
right and shit down on paper and he solves some crazy mathematical equation that
they had been trying to,
I should pull up the actual information so I don't,
it doesn't sound like I'm talking out of my ass,
but um,
he,
he Russian,
let me pull this up.
Russian song.
I'm going to just Google Russian scientists.
Come dog wins math prize.
It doesn't want it.
Let's see if that works.
And notice that I didn't use bing.
I used fucking Google.
Okay.
Cause these new commercials,
right.
You should try bing.
Bing is actually better than Google surprise being so crazy.
I like when a search engine is a good God damn time.
You know,
I tell you one thing though,
if you Google,
we had this thing on muffs said the other day.
If you Google that word,
boobs,
a safe serve,
safe search off.
You don't get any tits.
But if you go to Yahoo and do boobs,
you get tits.
But which one you don't Google.
Really?
Yeah.
Google's trying to hide the heads.
Sorry.
I understand.
Try and make that paper.
This is the dude.
Um,
he,
uh,
he's a
Russian scientists from Saint Petersburg.
His name is Gregory Bill Man.
He's a 40 year old man and he won the fields medal often described as mass
equivalent to the Nobel prize for a breakthrough in the study of shapes that
experts say might help scientists figure out the shape of the universe and super
offended by the way you said his name,
with that accurate Gregory bureau men to really offensive.
John [inaudible],
president of the International Mathematics Union said that he had urged Perlman
per p,
So I don't know what that is.
Oh Man.
Pirlo Pearlman Pearlman.
Anyway,
homeboy,
he urged homeboy to accept the metal,
but he said he felt isolated from the mathematics community and does not want to
be seen as a figurehead.
Wow.
He just didn't want the money.
He passed on $1 million money.
A million dollar prize.
Million Dollars.
Yep.
Besides shunning the award for his work in top topology.
He also seems uninteresting according to colleagues in a separate wouldn't
billion dollar prize.
He could win.
Providing the Poincare conjecture a theorem about the nature of multidimensional
space.
Whoa,
whoa indeed.
Whoa.
Yeah,
he's too smart.
Yeah.
That's a dude that's too smart and doesn't understand what $2 billion can get
you.
Cause he can get you a lot of cool shit.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're going to have to do,
one of the things you could do is move from Siberia with your million dollars.
Yeah.
You gotta be a really crazy
fuck to pass on 1 million bucks pocket.
But you probably also have to be a really crazy fuck to be able to think in such
a spectacular way.
It's like the fact that this guy,
I mean it's not that this guy wasn't successful because he's studied mathematics
only.
He put all his focus on mathematics.
But once he got really good at that,
well then he was able to capitalize on is excellence.
No,
no,
it's,
they offered him money and he said,
I don't want to go back to the shock.
And the things like [inaudible] papers.
I just realized too that I was talking about people's intelligence earlier in
this podcast and that if that guy met me,
he'd be like,
are you the dumbest?
Yeah.
Personally,
I've never spoken to somebody as stupid as you told me again.
Well,
I wonder what he would be like socially.
I wonder what's probably a little awkward.
I guess
maybe
they figured out sociology and he figured out the interaction between human
beings.
Then he becomes the coolest fucking guy in the world.
If he's that guy,
that guy,
he takes the two months and we all know that that guy,
that guy takes the 2 million definitely goes pimping.
You should double up on that shit.
You know what?
Someone just called somebody that I thought it was an awesome fucking expression
to call him a suitcase.
Pimp.
Suitcase pimps.
I've never heard of that.
I like that.
I have heard it many times,
but I hadn't heard it a while.
A suitcase pimp.
What's up?
Suitcase pimp.
It's a suitcase.
Pimps,
but it's not a,
it's not a
positive term.
A suitcase pimp is like a hustler,
you know?
It's like he's never got his shit together.
He's always like living out of a suitcase.
Somebody said some shit that was so cool to me that I just didn't get it.
You know when it's like two bits much cooler than you.
Somebody yelled that shit at me in Cleveland like I am.
So they calm me,
daisy,
and I was like,
cool.
I just don't know what the fuck you mean,
man.
In the porn world,
I use that term suitcase pimp.
Oh really?
Yeah.
In the porn world,
a suitcase pimp is the unemployed boyfriend of the porn star.
Oh,
that's a suitcase pen.
That's all over that industry support.
You've got to have support in that.
The craziest thing that those guys,
it's always those guys.
Yeah.
You know,
it's always a,
you got to get paid,
but it's strippers as well,
like a lot of strippers and especially like girls at work.
It really nasty,
but he's this and that.
You don't feel good about it.
Right.
They need a man and a man waiting for them when they get home to cuddle with and
snuggle,
trying to get out.
The memories of all those boners
and it's always a guy that's a loser because I mean,
you know a lot of guys out there right now,
it's tripper girlfriends going,
fuck you should.
Yeah.
But it's true.
If you're at home and you don't pay the bills and you don't,
you know,
you don't contribute to the household.
You're unemployed and you're girls out there sticking her pussy and guys faces.
There's a reason why that's not the conventional setup.
It's cause you're number one bro.
That's fine.
Basically the most awesome guy ever either,
bro.
Yes,
Bro.
And your band is awesome too.
And uh,
that Barb wire tat is looking fucking rat bro.
Does anybody do barbwire anymore?
I wonder if someone does it.
Ironically it's gotta be,
but the thing is,
it's ironic,
but you gotta be,
you gotta be rolling with a really a crew that really knows you to get your
ironic,
Ari has keep on trucking.
Tattoo does ride.
That's,
that's ironic.
And I think everyone gets that campaign has one too.
The silly one.
I forget what it is though,
on just like side or is tat somebody find out suitcase?
Yeah.
He's got a funny one.
Waterfalls.
Barb wire.
Come on.
You can't do that shit anymore,
right?
Do Girls still get tramp stamps?
I think so.
How many girls have gotten just a target?
Just put it an actual target aim here.
Yeah.
It's just like concentric rings.
Bullseye.
There's some freaky fucking ones,
uh,
around pussies on the Internet.
Right.
If you seen some of them,
we were like,
oh,
Mike,
I guess a demon's mouth that is around her box and you're like,
you really thought that that was going to be a good movie?
I think we'll,
I think that cat butthole belly button tattoo on is the grossest one.
It's just once but whole on your fucking tummy.
Yeah.
Mine would look really bad.
It's all here eating,
letting it all the time.
Yeah.
You Have Lynn,
I think the other day,
like a bug crowd in my belly button and then got squished when I was sleeping.
Really?
Like put my finger in there and this thing came out.
It looked like it like a squished bug.
Really big one now.
Like a called it.
Oh.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
sometimes it looks like spiders.
When I pull out the lint and there's all these hairs in them,
I'm like,
Oh,
is that a 70 legs spider?
And then I realize that it's just a ball end.
But yeah,
this girl got diarrhea tattooed on her back.
Come on.
Yeah,
like
the word diarrhea.
Diarrhea.
I guess
it's for dudes are trying to fuck her on the butt.
She's like,
I just want to steer you away right away.
That's going to go poorly.
Yeah,
there's a,
if you look on Google images under a tramp stamps something one girl has like a
whole Bible passage written on her lower back up to her ass.
Is that the last shit you want to be reading when you're banging a hot chick
doggy style?
Cause their ass looks tremendous too and is a bible verse.
It's a giant literary tattoo.
But maybe it's really like,
Hey,
I want you to come right here in a second,
but it just written really fast Corinthians.
No,
this is,
this is what it says.
This is,
this bitch is so crazy.
Love is patient.
Love is kind.
It does not envy.
Love.
This is all written on her ass.
Love is never boastful,
not conceited nor rude.
It's hard to cause the curve of her ass.
Something self seeking
commonly,
commonly not commonly are angered,
argued,
argued.
It keeps no secrets,
blah,
blah.
It does to delight in evil but rejoices and I can't read it.
Blah Blah,
blah,
protects,
trusts,
hopes and preserves.
There is never a blah,
blah,
something face.
There is no limit to its faith.
If you could open it,
this is all in her ass.
If you can't translate it just said raped by father.
Keeps going dude.
There is this honor as faith.
Yes,
this is all show you.
But the greatest of them all is love.
Look at that.
Oh my God.
Like she like wrote,
I mean it's a pair.
I think I would lose my erection show.
Did you see this woman in Columbus?
The one that has all our tattoos including Thomson [inaudible] mine,
but I know her.
She's awesome.
Yeah,
that's a good sign.
It.
Yeah.
That's dumb.
And Alyssa,
right?
Yup.
Did you sign it?
No.
I didn't sign it cause she didn't ask me to.
But uh,
I signed Dom's leg.
Yeah.
Um,
her brother,
I hope she covers all that shit out with a big Gucci Mane.
Ice Cream cone.
Have you seen that?
Yeah.
Gucci Mane put an ice cream color on its face.
Well what's his name?
Uh,
and in paper
pull up the picture.
Humane ice cream cones,
baby.
Big Baby Bird Man's oil.
Well,
oil drill on his oil drill oil.
It's real going tattooed on the side of it.
He does.
He really?
Yes ma'am.
He's got giant stars over his to right.
It's insane.
No,
just tattooed his fucking head.
Jason Ellis,
he put a g look at,
damn
got lightening bolts.
May My,
I can be on fire.
Gucci Mane is crazy.
Look at him.
He put an ice cream cone on his face.
It says burr.
You see it?
You see it on the cone.
Be Our,
our,
our and the Tattoo guy.
I was like,
okay,
how does ice,
Matt,
could you,
um,
I want,
I'm going to get,
have to get you to request this on video.
And then I need you to get,
I need you to write this down.
Yeah,
come on man.
Just tattoo it.
I ain't going to change my mind about a pecan on my face,
man.
Yo Dog.
Don't be giving me no vanilla ice cream.
I Hate Vanilla.
I want a cone of good one.
Like a waffle type motherfucker.
I screen
them.
Delicious cones with the upper level that is like styrofoam,
like craziest pourer
ice cream.
Well he's got Alicia those fees cause yeah,
like writing us phase two.
He just uses face to draw and you see what it says under his and I can you read
what pissed off those things on his eye under resign or those are tattoos too.
Oh my God.
It looks like it's under his,
I says something.
What the fuck Bobby or some shit.
What does that say?
I see,
what does it say?
1000 vague.
I don't know.
It's hard to say 10 times 10 with the s on the amp.
So yeah.
And on the other side he has,
it looks like a dove or something like that in the Honda's.
Yeah.
That that dude is probably irrational.
Gucci.
Yeah.
This is music.
Like,
have you ever heard his music?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Is it good?
I mean,
yeah.
Gucci Man.
He's got some,
he's got some hits out there,
man.
Yeah.
What's your favorite?
I don't know.
I don't remember the name.
Hmm.
Can we listen to a little bit of the future?
Heard Gucci Mane?
Yeah.
Are we going to get kicked off of Youtube if we put this up?
Does Gucci Mane Independent?
Is he out there working for the man?
What does he have?
So many?
He's got a verse here cause I have a big deal.
He's got a big
are they haven't those big deals anymore with the record in the streets.
So we just talking about the other day about how you used to be able to go to a
town and he'd go to tower records and you can go pick up a CD.
Yeah.
There's no tower records anymore.
No.
There's no virgin mega store.
I remember though the,
of course I got some,
have you seen little poopy little poopy poopy?
Have you seen him?
He's a,
he's a rapper.
Nine year old rapper and his name's little poopy.
It is the best.
All right,
let me say it a little poop.
No,
no,
no.
Pull that other thing up.
I want to hear Gucci Man.
I want to hear a little poopy
hangs out with the fake Rick Ross.
Please isolate.
I'm want to hear Gucci Man poopy.
The fake Rick Ross
is a,
he's doing well.
That fake or across.
Oh,
there's no need for that music.
He's got better shit.
He's got another,
he's know for as big as hit.
Let's do,
yeah,
yeah.
You should get it in another,
that's the sample.
But the fact that he's capable of that,
he's mad hood man.
He's got to make it for the streets.
You know what I'm saying?
Bad Hood.
Is that a mad hood song?
I think definitely that.
That sounds like some shit you would hear Bubba and ATL if you were bowling on,
it sounds like you'd locked him in a garage with a hundred cars running and made
a breathe the fumes for a year.
Definitely.
And then you brought him out.
Barely alive.
This is a little,
this is terrible to,
okay.
Okay.
I don't want to get to the little Gucci Man.
Pull up Gucci Mane.
His greatest hit.
Try to find groups you means greatest basely sorted by view count and that was,
oh well then do a search for it and yeah,
he's got to have a bigger hit than that for sure.
You're defending it.
I want you to get a good sample of Gucci.
Here's a good,
okay.
No,
this is not going to be key chain as fuck.
It's going to put something else on.
Some buttons going to put Rebecca Black Friday.
No.
Uh,
that chick hurt.
Her deal was they gave her a bunch of money.
Remember that?
Okay.
Becca black.
No,
no,
no.
I just heard creation right.
Then
how do you even know who that is?
It was a big deal.
She got like a,
I feel like I know you and then I feel like a dome.
Oh,
like a million dollar advance,
which was not as common now for an unsafe like unknown artist.
And then that album sell well at all.
Really?
When was this?
I think within like the last year.
Huh?
I don't know anybody today and I'm just,
so I'm out of the loop.
I'm pretty out of it.
I know stuff that like that because it's in the news and I know I'm mostly the
music I grew up on.
I'm not aware of a lot of the new Shit Gucci Mane.
I know because you know like a son to me.
But
there's so much music that was been hin been made.
And when you think about the fact that from 1960 whatever to today,
you know you want to go crazy,
you want to go Robert Johnson,
you can listen to some shit recorded in the 30s and forties right?
Yeah.
But think about that two d till today.
What a gigantic pile of music that I've seen.
There's so much out there.
What a body of work.
Yeah,
all the different musicians in the sixties the seventies that fit.
Oh my God,
there's so much music.
It's like to come up with new stuff.
It's like to really get me into it.
It has to be like the black keys spent
raising some money.
Like did he blow through and cars and shit?
Yeah.
Like he blew through a lot of it.
He was on that broke um,
special that the air and he was just like,
if somebody pulled up,
you know,
and like a Ferrari,
you're like,
yeah,
that's just hot.
I got a top that shit.
So then he would go like the day,
that day I got the land by what the brains blown out man.
Like just to top each other guys would just buy shit to show off,
you know,
to compete each other on it.
They say that there's some ungodly number of people.
It's like 80% of all NFL players are broke and in bankruptcy within two years of
retiring.
It's,
it's incredible.
I mean,
you know,
the older I get,
the more I understand the younger guys having no like 0 million cents and also
zero Fike financial Iq.
Like they don't know.
No.
The 21 to like here's the $3 million.
And they're like,
Ooh,
let's get this part is 22 yeah.
Yeah.
I imagine it's crazy,
but it's crazier when they're like,
he played 10,
12,
16 years like Iverson and he's blown through like $200 million in your lab or
some broke now.
Yes.
And how old is he now?
He is 37 something like that.
His body's not working right anymore.
Oh,
he's down head.
The NBA.
Yeah.
And he's,
and he's trying to play,
but he's running through well into nine figures,
you know.
Wow.
I mean,
I,
you know,
and that's,
you have to consider,
he made a lot of,
he didn't endorsements.
So nine figures.
Nine figures.
Yeah.
Make seven figures.
Girls would be like,
wow,
he makes seven figures.
It's like,
can make nine nine a Bluetooth at all.
Yeah.
That shit crazy,
man.
Woopsies it's crazy that
it's so much.
They,
they interviewed one uh,
defensive,
like a guy on the,
on the,
the special on the,
the broke thing.
And he was like,
I don't know why man.
But he was like,
everybody had a car wash.
He's like,
we all had a fucking car wash man.
That shit.
That shit did not last.
Like we all spent money on a car.
We bought a carwash.
Yeah man,
you ain't got your own carwash.
Ah,
and Bart Scott had the bay.
He was like,
you buy shit.
It's Anessa.
He's not broke at all.
And he's still playing and he's like,
I'm smarter with my money.
But he's like,
you know,
everybody's a stupid purchase.
I bought a coat,
I think it was made a wolf
and he's like,
I wore that shit once and it was like $35,000
you can wear a wolf collide.
Think so man Christ I get wolf coat.
That shit would be my dogs at attack it.
Let Little Wolf in the house like that.
I was thinking about how absurd is it,
like how unprepared my mind is to see grown men in any type of,
for like if they're not,
if you don't have like an AK 47 in your hand or you're not a coke dealer,
are you stepping off a team plane?
Yeah.
I'm not like mentally prepared to see a man in for,
you know,
you're rushing or,
yeah.
Eat inside beer garden.
Patch it in your hand.
Sure.
And you've got your collision to cop and you're ready to fucking get down.
But other than that,
walking around with dude have first shit on.
So warm.
Have you ever worn it?
Fur coat.
I put my mother's on when I was like 12.
Yeah.
I have a friend who,
uh,
is a rich guy back in Boston and he wore a full length fur coat and a,
I go,
what is that?
It's like,
it's a mink coat.
I go,
you're wearing a mink coat?
He goes,
yeah.
you got to try it on.
I go,
really?
He goes,
yeah,
try it on.
Try It on and go.
Okay.
I'm like,
oh my God.
Crazy.
It's so warm.
They're so comfortable.
You know,
it's gross when they have the legs still attached around the top.
That's gangster shrunk and curves.
That's pretty worn.
Shrunken heads.
Look,
could I got my fucking conquest?
Yeah.
It keeps you warm.
People like,
well,
you know,
I really think it's fucked up that uh,
people kill minx it is fucked up that people kill.
Makes it totally is.
But you know what happens when people don't kill Max,
they get eaten alive by walls.
Yeah,
yeah.
They get killed.
Like they don't live like,
it's not like a mixed is going to live forever.
I get it though.
It's like it's tough.
It's tough to,
you know,
rationally look at it and say,
you think it's okay to kill an animal just for it's for,
I say no.
I say the only way you should kill an animal is if you're going to use the whole
animal.
He,
it,
he did for sure.
I mean that I think is the most important.
And if you use the other parts of it as well.
Yeah,
but just the for man,
that seems fucked up.
I agree.
All right.
And then what's even worse or on the same line is when they kill the fucking
elephants for the tusks,
it's dark.
It's dark.
There's a big controversy about that with a pool players because uh,
there's a lot of parts of pool cues that they use ivory for.
Oh really?
Yeah,
but it has to be pre ban ivory and they,
they're really good at like monitoring where the ivory comes from.
And occasionally people get arrested for selling illegal ivory.
Like there was a guy,
there was a god,
he distributed stuff for pool,
a cute makers like a ivory and exotic woods and stuff along those lines.
And he got arrested a few years back because he,
uh,
he was selling illegal ivory.
They take that shit very seriously.
Oh,
I lad.
But you're allowed to have it.
You're allowed to have the band ivory.
Yeah.
And the idea is that first of all,
those animals are dead.
Okay.
And they killed so many of them,
so it was worth so much money that between,
I think it was like 1980 and eight whenever the band was in institute in 1987
there,
their population dipped by over a million.
I think they were at like 1.5 million and they were down to 500,000.
So,
um,
it's,
it's imperative that people understand that like a lot of the ivory that you use
today and stuff is like,
there's so much of it,
you don't have to kill anything for it.
And if you don't use it,
it's kind of fucked because that means somebody murdered these animals for their
ivory and then didn't use him for things.
Yeah.
But if you murdered him now and use the robbery for shit,
it's fucked up.
Like it's a real gray area.
If you look at it that way,
it's like,
would you be willing to have ivory tusks if you found them in a store in your
house,
like mounted?
They're beautiful and the crazy to look at it and like if you've ever seen him
in a minute,
there's a mammoth Tusk at this museum.
It's fucking fascinating,
man.
It's amazing.
But as far as we know,
nobody ever shot a mammoth.
Right,
right,
right.
Dealing with an elephant that some dude put a sniper bullet through his fucking
brain and see,
I think it make me too sad around probably,
right.
Yeah.
Because the only,
there's only one way you get those things.
And the animal will two ways.
The animal dies on its own,
which is pretty fucking rare.
No,
that's not how usually you get to live a long time.
They can live a long time.
Yeah.
Or you shoot that.
That's the other problem.
They live a long time and they're fucking smart.
You know?
Elephants are smart.
Elephants a recognize each other after not seeing each other for like 20 years.
Like it's crazy.
It's crazy to watch.
They run over and grab trunks,
wrap their trunks around each other and from knowing a cuddling practically,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's fucked up that year.
It was,
people just slaughtered them for ivory.
That's the thing too is you're,
they're killing these big beautiful animals just for one thing and then they're
like,
yeah,
that's cool.
And then they move along.
Those animals will fucking kill you too though.
Are these Elvis got,
fuck.
All right.
Wow.
You imagine having to carry that look at the size of that thing in.
I don't think they have big decks too.
I think he's trying to go deep,
but it's like barely has a deck.
Ooh.
There is that look at the size of his body as muscles on the thing.
You ever thought about that?
That'd be cool if they walk around with that all the time.
What do you think he squats that guy?
Oh,
he could do a house,
but a whole house on his back.
He'll squatted.
Oh my God.
Look at the size of his muscles.
What a freaky fucking animal.
He just finished wrapping right now.
He's just like,
ah.
He's in an intense,
elephants are so much,
so much weirder than the Avatar people.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
they are.
They're so weird.
That trunk is completely alien.
A long knows that pick shit up.
What?
There's no other thing like it.
Oh,
just see that slow.
That's a huge data hog on that
size of that thing.
Holy Shit.
Oh my God.
Are we allowed to show 'em elephant hogs on your streams?
It's okay because it's like nature.
Yeah.
That was,
uh,
that was a big deck that could kill you.
That's,
that's definitely kind of things.
A horses dicta I don't think that,
I think that it's bigger.
No,
no,
no.
We just saw it right there.
Horses ever ridiculous decks.
A lot of people don't know this.
Smaller and yeah,
we'll uh,
we'll be visiting again with,
um,
our friend Dr. Christopher Ryan.
He's going to be a pack on the podcast.
He's the author of that book,
Sex at dawn and uh,
he'll be on a Monday the 25th.
Um,
and uh,
looking forward to that.
But one of the things that he said is that gorillas in his book,
he talks about Dick size.
Gorillas have really little decks and the reason they have little dicks
is because they didn't have to like have a big Dick to dominate.
They just have a bunch of chicks who listened to them.
The girls aren't slutty,
they stay put and he doesn't really need a big Dick.
So he's got this little tiny,
tiny dick cause it's not about her,
it's about him getting on top,
pinning her down,
sticking little tiny dick and there she ain't going anywhere.
He doesn't have to like prove himself to her.
Right.
Whereas chimpanzee chicks are whore.
Chimpanzees don't run any sort of a brothel.
They don't have like a heroin checks like a gorilla does.
Chimpanzees can't rock it like that.
Chimpanzee girls are just too slutty.
So chimpanzees,
because of this,
have enormous testicles.
And the reason why they have enormous tax goals on a male primate,
the testicle size is directly proportionate to the amount of promiscuous females
that are in your area.
Really?
Yes.
So if the females are monogamous and you don't have to compete to earn their
trust and their,
their sex,
your balls shrivel up,
Dick shrivels up.
You don't need as much is,
but when there's,
when there's competition,
when there's a lot of shit going down,
that's when you need to have big balls and a big deck.
Humans have the biggest dicks out of all the primates.
Human dicks are bigger than chimps,
chimps her next.
But it's because human girls to the sluttiest to the sluts and all the animal
community.
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
Those dirty bitches.
So our decks have to oh yeah.
And the big of the dude's Dick is the most likely bigger,
the amount of slots he's around.
Wow.
And that crazy genetically like in his environment where you know,
he was born and conceived ball size too.
Yeah.
I mean,
over the course of obviously generation after generation,
it's not like it's an instant thing.
Your mom's a whore,
you got a giant deck.
Right.
It's not like that,
but,
but that's the reason for it.
Wow.
And then fucked.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But it makes sense.
I mean we,
we,
we look at all sexual things so emotionally,
you know,
we always look at it like,
we look at it as ourselves,
you know,
like,
Whoa,
what did you care about the fucking,
what does secure,
how big my Duke is.
If you love me,
you know?
But nature doesn't care about your emotions at all.
Nature doesn't care about,
you know,
your,
your desire for acceptance and it doesn't,
it cares about numbers.
It cares about who is going to make the most babies.
Who's going to be the most effective breeding?
Who's going to have the bigger dick that's going to transfer to his children
having a bigger deck?
What?
Who's going to have the most ambitious personality that transfers into the
genetics and passes on epigenetically to offspring and they become more
aggressive and more ambitious.
And I mean that's nature favors.
Nature favors like the numbers of the whole nature isn't really like looking at
your emotions and your problems.
Your emotions are basically a trick and all of them are just set up to get you
to do shit the nature wants you to do.
Whether it's your emotions for your,
you know,
your connection to your loved ones,
it's real as it is and it's palpable.
It is to you.
It's really also uh,
uh,
it's,
it's sort of a reward system that the universe has set up to
make sure that you keep interacting with people,
keep breeding and they,
and keep perpetuating the civilization in its current form.
Like all these emotions are all,
it's all set up to make sure that you keep the universal then give a fuck about
you,
right?
Yeah.
Is busy constructing a gram design that you're a part of and that's also your
big deck.
You Big Dick as a part of that?
Tommy Big Dick is a part of about the is grand design.
It's part of the blueprint.
Yeah.
Result of it.
What is that?
What do you,
what is this?
It's that thing that doctor found the other,
oh,
the doctor found the alien.
Hmm.
It looks realistic.
Totally looks like a real person.
I'm a so I thought you were.
So is this something so much worse?
This is a birth defect.
I don't think that's funny at all.
What is this?
I don't know.
It's listed as a frog person.
Half.
Yeah.
Half human.
Half Frog and cephalic baby.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a baby with a terrible disease buddy.
Oh,
sure.
That was real.
Yeah.
I thought that was a frog.
No,
it looks like a frog.
It looks like a frog,
but it's a sick to z and it funny like it was funny for a couple seconds and
then it wasn't funny.
Yeah.
It's funny when we thought it was an animation just like that,
that one does.
He like this disease?
I was freaky.
Oh,
what is that?
I forget the name of the disease.
It's where it's,
uh,
oh yeah.
I don't really want to anyway.
Yeah,
don't watch that.
That's a horrible baby.
It looks like a lizard.
Yeah,
she's just mad.
There's a lot of bad bad rolls of the dice you can get for reals.
Do you ever feel bad about the midget joke?
He do.
Um,
it's talking about bad rolls of the dice.
I mean,
I,
I felt badly.
I haven't done that in a long time cause you know,
I just,
it got old to me like just saying it,
but I haven't said it a while,
but um,
I felt bad when this,
this couple one time at a show got really like the woman was crying hysterically
over it.
Um,
whoa.
Like it was so weird.
Is she a big fan of little house on the prairie or she is a,
what's a show with a midget?
Um,
oh,
the big people.
Little world.
Right.
That's one.
I don't know why I said a little house in my prayer.
I bottle little.
Was She,
uh,
the wizard of Oz?
Maybe it was.
That was,
that was it.
It was maybe that was a big one for her.
She really,
yeah,
they got upset about that.
She talked to,
you know,
her husband followed me offstage to the bathroom.
Oh,
Jay.
Anybody.
He goes a really funny stuff,
really funny.
And I was like,
thanks man.
I thought it was just like a regular guy thinks will happen.
Then he goes in and then,
um,
you know that that image is stuff you do,
you know those jokes.
And I was like,
Oh shit,
I really thought it,
it's almost gonna Punch me.
And I was like,
Yep.
And he goes,
um,
yeah,
so you know,
my,
my son is a dwarf.
And I was like,
yeah.
And he started talking and he,
I go,
I
get it,
man.
I understand.
He's like,
you understand,
I go,
I understand how what I said is offensive to you.
And he said,
it's not offensive to me.
It's offensive to him and what he's going to become.
And I was like,
yeah,
I get it,
man.
So the next show,
oh,
and then after that,
the fucking,
the guy went back to see,
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
And I was like,
that sucked.
And I was standing out front and then at the end of the show,
or actually no,
the show was still going on.
I saw him and a woman talking to the manager and she was hysterical,
like just crying and screaming.
And I was,
she didn't know that I was watching.
I was watching from like 25 feet away and the guy,
she's telling the manager and I can hear her saying he's such an asshole,
he's such an asshole.
And I can hear the manager going,
he's not an asshole,
he's not an asshole.
He's a nice guy.
And I was like,
I couldn't believe that he was saying that.
And then he was like,
I'll tell you what I'll do,
I'll give you tickets to come back.
You tell me any show you want to come to and I'll give you tickets to that.
And then they were like,
okay.
And they were leaving and then he stopped them and he was like,
just so you know,
I can't promise you the same shit won't happen at that next show.
And they were like,
I guess so.
And then they,
they left.
Um,
so I felt badly that I upset a family and I get,
you know,
like would upset them.
But I still think that the joke for the most part was funny.
Like I thought it was a funny joke,
the bid or whatever.
So I kind of thought about it and then,
you know,
I like,
I stopped doing it really out of boredom.
Not really that I,
I spent the next show,
I made a joke about that couple.
I told him how the lady got upset at me and I was like,
Hey lady,
that joke,
I'm not,
the one that fills you up was spoiled milk.
Don't get mad at me.
Did you say on stage?
Oh,
that's fucked up.
But I mean it wasn't that familiar with spoiled little girl.
It's so wrong.
But I really feel like it's,
it goes back to,
we were talking about,
I mean,
and I realized that it's super subjective and people can definitely tell me that
that joke is not funny.
I respect that.
I'm not,
I'm not in the,
I don't take the position as I'm going to argue with you about how things are
funny or something that I said.
I'm just saying that when I said it,
I thought it was funny that that's what I'm going out on.
I thought when I said it was funny,
uh,
there are jokes that I've done in the past that I go,
those are just,
yeah.
I mean some of course are easy jokes.
Some are really just jokes that I get bored of saying it's,
it's,
it's not funny to me anymore now because I didn't think it was a funny thing at
first.
We were just bored of it.
Yeah.
I got bored of it,
so I stopped saying it.
Yeah.
And there's stop with this.
You don't like it?
No,
I don't want this shit.
Um,
why?
It's like when you,
when you create a bit,
you know,
when you have a bit
and you do a bit that's like super controversial.
Yes.
We are essentially doing is you're establishing your parameters.
Like know if you're going to go see my show,
you're going to get this.
You might get this,
it goes this far.
Right,
and there's certain guys that you know that like you,
you know when you go see them,
they're basically not going to talk about anything controversial.
They're not going to say anything mean or cruel.
They're not.
And so you know that guy's parameters too,
right?
Like if you go see Jerry Seinfeld for instance,
you're not going to get a whole lot of ass to mouth jokes.
Jerry Seinfeld is dropped so many of his ATM until imagine if he's like,
if you got divorced and just started doing ecstasy and hit well,
I realize I'm almost dead.
So a and I'm ranch so I only go asked him out.
I don't want to talk to them.
Why would I talk to you when she'll go ask them out?
You explained it to me.
You'd say,
I'm stupid Jesus.
She'll go ass to mouth and you won't put it in her ass.
He was like simple math.
I just put it in her mouth.
Why are we arguing when I can just be driving a Porsche?
Yeah.
I mean,
you know that you go see him,
you're not going to get a midget joke,
you're not going to get some.
Yeah.
But this part of like establishing,
establishing yourself as a comic is you got to know like who's going to say
fucked up shit.
And the comedians that say fucked up shit to me,
even if I don't laugh at it,
like I'm not particularly fond of midget jokes,
but I love the fact that a guy is going to do a joke about anything.
You're not going to worry about pissing people off.
You're just going to do fucked up what?
And so like you're in a certain frequency that I enjoy comedy wise.
Like if I was just a fan,
if I wasn't a comedian,
I would totally go see you.
I'd be psyched because of that element of danger because of that element of,
you know,
fucked up Agnes.
Yeah,
no,
that's an expense.
But it isn't it.
I mean it's like I don't you feel the same way,
like your favorite kind of comedy we watch,
right?
I mean,
it's why I think I,
I got into comedy because I love comedy and the guy's like,
I always say it and it,
I guess it's not,
it's not,
it's not entirely fair.
And I'm aware of that,
but in my mind,
what I say to people who as a fan who don't do things like that,
um,
I just in my mind go,
well,
I'm going to be bored.
Yeah.
I want to see somebody do something fucked up,
top about fucked up shit.
I want to talk,
I want to hear jokes about drugs and sex and fucked up thing because that's what
makes me laugh.
Yeah.
So that's why I want to see,
and I want to see people that work in that circle.
That's what interests me.
Yeah.
That's all that interesting too.
And for the longest time,
uh,
I was told that that was the wrong kind of comedy.
I was told that you shouldn't do that kind of comedy because it's cheap and easy
jokes.
But I was like,
but God,
that's what I want to hear.
That's what,
yeah,
that's what you're like,
when I knew a guy was coming into town,
when I,
when I remember when I first started doing standup,
I went to see like a bunch of stand ups when I first started.
Like what the,
for my first year of comedy I was real lucky because that at that time in Boston
there was a couple big national clubs.
There wasn't a lot of national clubs back then.
Like there was an Improv in New York,
but there wasn't even an Improv it in la yet or not an Improv in la.
There wasn't even an Improv Boston yet.
It was an Improv in New York and Improv in La and the Boston one opened I think
in like 89 or 90 or something along those lines.
Yeah.
So like the guys who were like wanting to work in like in travel the country,
there wasn't as many options as there is now.
So we would get like top level headliners in every week.
Like catch a rising star and Cambridge,
I don't even know.
I think it's under,
I think it went under,
which is God damn shame.
Cause I went to see,
I saw Kevin Meeney there.
I saw that was,
I was in high school.
I just graduated high school.
When I saw Kevin me there,
I saw a rich Jenny there.
I saw so many comics that were like big name headliners come through and I
always enjoyed it when they were fucked up.
I remember I would go way out of my way if I knew that a guy was going to do
some crazy shit.
Yeah,
talk about some crazy shit if it went,
went nutty and if it didn't go nutty.
I understood.
I understood it didn't,
but I was so I would get a giddy joy.
It's like Doug Stan hope was doing,
have you heard his new bit about fantasy football?
Phenomenal.
It's so fucked up.
First of all,
Doug's crowd is so much different than my crowd.
They're very different.
They're very different and they're there.
There's,
I mean there's a lot of crossover,
but his fucking people are ham or really hammer and talking through.
I mean they were so loud.
It was w we went to see him at Cincinnati.
We went to go in and I did,
yeah,
we did our show at the Taft and then we came over to go bananas.
Oh,
we had a great fucking time go down.
This is awesome shit.
And then we went to Mc Levy's,
we went next door to the bar and standup and I were bartending you bartender too
for awhile,
didn't you?
I bartended for a half hour.
I was still bartending.
You guys are gone.
I'm like,
wait,
why am I doing this?
Yeah,
we were handing out drinks and giving away drinks for free.
I would give away like 10 drinks and then I would just take 100 bucks and throw
it in the,
in the the uh,
tip bear.
I'm like,
I don't know.
I go,
I don't know how much this stuff costs,
so I'm just giving people booze and I'll just come and start paying for it.
So I would give people,
I would,
I was giving out free drinks and then I would throw money in that bucket.
I was like,
I don't know if it evens out.
Like we were in Australia and you bought everybody that ever walked into a bar,
a drink.
We went off in Australia.
That was one of the few times in my life where we purposely decided to go deep.
Yeah.
That was pretty fun.
We,
me and Tommy and Eddie Bravo,
we were in Sydney and we went to the movies when we were super disappointed with
that stupid fucking island.
Shutter island.
Yeah.
Leonardo di Caprio.
Oh,
psych.
None of this actually happened.
I'm actually crazy.
Ah,
we were so angry and we're angry.
It's so many people that weren't angry.
That was one that was more upsetting.
That was way more upsetting.
Somebody.
People like that movie.
Yeah.
So we decided to go to Taiwan on,
and we went to this local bar and uh,
it just,
it just started,
you know,
we,
we got some shots we made,
so we met some friends and they made some friends,
some nice people that were there,
wanted to take a couple of pictures.
We took a pictures,
and then when somebody wanted to take a picture,
I'm like,
come on mother fucker.
You want to drink?
Let's trank cause come on with drinking.
You weren't and I just pointed people you want to drink,
you want to know who's in,
who's in.
Are you guys in WWE?
I was buying drinks for 2030 people at a time.
Like the wages,
super stacking trays of shots and like just giant group of people were all like
cheering and dragon by the way.
There's nothing after that experience.
That's the coolest way you can ever spend your first night in a foreign country.
Oh.
Like thank you for having me in your country.
Everybody gets drinks.
That was the most fucking fun.
I spend more money in that bar than I've ever spent in a bar.
I hope so.
Yeah,
it was thousands of dollars,
but it was so fun.
You were nice enough to tell people we've been buying people drinks all night
when we walked out.
Like now we have it.
He's been buying people's drinks.
I brought 50.
Dot.
While we were all together.
So it's we,
yeah,
that was fun,
man.
It was the way to do it.
I mean,
yeah,
cause it was like we,
we,
you know,
when we were,
when you're all drunk,
okay.
When everybody's drunk,
when you're dealing with 20,
30,
I mean how many people were there at the end?
We had a lot of people who are doing,
yeah,
there's hundreds of people,
Dude.
And we're high fiving people.
But we made sure that everyone was fucked up.
Yeah.
So we were all in the same boat of course.
And everyone was very friendly,
was happy and everybody was friendly and people were all like huggy high five
take a picture,
you know,
they were all friendly and the waiters were happy.
The bartenders were happy,
they were all laughing.
It's like the fact that you can make a moment like that happen,
but God damn did I pay for it the next day.
Ooh.
Give business manager call.
Hey,
what happened?
No,
I'm my head.
I did.
The money was well spent with my,
my dome was fucking pounds.
That's the shit thing to do too because the next day like I had a really fire up
to do this show.
I was like noticeably slower,
you know?
And I think I was probably even noticeably like slow the next day when the UFC
was on.
Really?
It's like,
yeah,
probably man,
I got drunk.
I mean that was pretty God damn drunk.
You can't get that drunk and bounce bounce right back here.
Also that drunk coming off of that flight 16 hours or whatever it is.
Yeah.
And then,
but then we didn't like our bodies.
I already went past like when we should have gone to bed,
which probably like I know where like in the early evening or something,
we rolled that out into late night there.
Yeah,
we did like a full day and change over.
They say you should do that though to avoid like to,
to reset your clock.
They say just have one day where you just stay up,
stay up,
stay up.
So that way when you know 10:00 PM the right time rolls around,
you're going to be so fucking tired.
You know,
if you could just power through.
But if you take a nap you could fuck the whole,
yeah.
Well I've had that where you wake up and you're like,
we're the fucking marine.
Like really scared for a moment like that.
You don't know where you are.
Yeah.
I had that happen before.
The worst is when you're in England and he can't go to bed till like 6:00 AM
because it's eight hours ahead or something done.
Right.
Was all of us.
Yeah.
It's probably like in the seven,
eight some Australia was like a whole day.
It's all day.
Yeah.
Which has even nuttier.
You know,
that's,
that's a,
that's a bizarre,
I did South Africa,
that was like a half,
I think it's like 12 hour difference.
It's pretty great.
Like it throws you over.
Yeah.
How many hours is that flight?
It was from Atlanta.
They do a direct,
uh,
15 and change to South Africa.
You Act from Atlanta?
Yeah.
How long were you there for?
Two and almost three weeks.
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
It was great.
I was it God.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
Really loved it.
Yeah.
What was so great about it?
Um,
everything.
I mean people were so god Damn Nice and friendly and appreciative.
The shows were all fantastic.
We got treated great.
It was a,
it was a blast,
man.
So did you have any prejudices about going to Africa?
Not really.
I mean,
I knew that like once it was booked,
um,
the only thing that I had,
you have to think about,
uh,
you know,
his disease stuff,
so you have to get certain shots.
But like,
I thought it was gonna be fun.
I'd heard good things about doing like standup in South Africa for a while now,
so I was totally excited to go.
I'm all about anywhere I get an offer abroad.
I think that's,
to me it's not,
um,
I get excited about it really.
Why do you want to get excited?
I just think it's fun,
man.
I mean like my,
it's my job and then somebody would want to see me do this like thousands of,
I like checking out places,
so it's fun to go to Australia.
It's fun to go to South Africa,
England.
Like that's all I entertaining.
To me.
It's fun.
I just remembered your opening joke.
Where in Australia?
Can you remember it?
Yeah.
Uh,
no.
What was it about being on the plane for so long that you think you're trimming?
Oh yeah.
Am I dead?
Like well,
right.
Yeah.
Oh,
I remember there was a bit,
yeah.
I mean,
then they get it.
My Dad,
you'd get off and you said,
well,
I must be in heaven because there's no black people.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That was for,
I was so far as your opening joke in Sydney.
Yeah.
But they light up.
Oh,
they troubles Joe.
It was a joke.
It's like how you said at the very beginning and everybody knew it.
Nobody was like,
that's fucked up man.
Like,
yeah.
Yeah.
It was a joke.
It was funny.
And they have a totally different feeling for black people and then we do as
well because that's not like their cultural underclass or cultural underclass is
not like former slaves.
It's aborigines.
Right.
It's like a totally different sort of a holocaust that happened over there told
me the,
it's like this whole dark period of American history,
the shameful period there is a shameful,
but it's shameful towards the aborigine people.
It's totally,
totally different sort of,
uh,
underclass.
I made a joke there.
I got that.
They didn't think it was so funny about that when I went back and looked up to
the Auburn,
but,
but it was a joke,
man.
The Melbourne would be more sensitive.
They're more sensitive,
but really it was most sensitive.
It wasn't really the room,
it was the press like the guy writing the review.
It's not like the room lost it.
Right.
Instead it made its way into an article about how offensive and racist and stuff
it was.
You know what I mean?
Horse.
Yeah.
Well most,
most people that are going to write articles about something getting,
yeah.
Excited to be upset because if I,
even if we're talking right now and you're like right about how fucking much you
hate American Airlines and be like,
all right,
here goes a blog.
Like oh yeah,
and I can tell you this story and I just write that.
Yeah,
of course.
Like it's fun to write that.
Did you read that one?
Uh,
there was a broader view of a Guy Fieri,
whatever the fuck his name is,
restaurant in Manhattan.
It was so scathing.
Yeah.
It went public.
Were people like,
what the fuck?
Like it was.
It was such a brutal review.
Right.
I wonder how accurate it was.
Well,
I wonder how I imagined it.
It's somewhat accurate,
but some of the hatred for that restaurant comes from that guy's feeling about
God and not the restaurant.
If you took a guy out of the equation,
you just send them there.
Sure.
It would not be as vicious.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
Yeah,
it's pro,
well,
it's also the,
the hype that comes with that.
I mean,
if you want to be a celebrity chef,
you better knock my dick in the dirt and I come to your fucking place and to go
there and to get some,
you know,
whack ass Applebee's.
Apple Mannequins.
Yeah.
All right.
The,
the whole celebrity chef thing.
It's a very odd thing.
And then like all of a sudden,
and we had Julia child and that was it.
Yeah.
For the longest time.
Who else did we have?
Who else is celebrity chef was there a man slept the French,
the French guy,
the galloping gourmet.
Remember that guy?
Is that,
I remember the guy who,
he's been on TV for years now.
The French guy,
he's kind of older,
older French chef.
I forget his name,
but he's been on,
well,
whatever.
I mean it's everyone.
It's a fascinating thing because it's like all you had was like a,
like a couple of examples and then Wolfgang puck got famous.
That's right.
He's,
he's been big for a while now.
Yeah.
He's like,
I feel like he's the one that made Emeral got famous for a little bit and people
like,
will you shut the fuck up with that?
Bam.
Stop that.
Because he was like,
damn,
he knew that.
Like he needed a tagline.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
But he just shoved it right down her throat.
That's right.
And then we got Bordain,
which is awesome.
Well,
boardings the first,
I think an example of what a kitchen is really staffed with,
right.
You know,
wild punk rocker type dudes with Mexicans working side by side.
Yeah.
You know,
and he's honest about the experience.
That's what it's awesome.
Yeah.
And he has a,
a genuine passion for cooking.
Yeah.
It a,
I never
worked in a kitchen other than like in high school I did work for Papa Ginos or
in the kitchen [inaudible] worked at Newport creamery like Megan burgers and
stuff like that,
but I've never worked in like a real restaurant.
But he had an episode once where they showed him actually working in a
restaurant,
like keeping up with all these orders as they came in at time and all these food
and,
and how hard it is and how much of a fucking stressful like high stress,
fast paced Gig it is.
It's like wow.
He really opens up your eyes to how difficult and how much artistic like flare
is involved in the culinary arts,
you know?
Fantastic.
Yeah.
There's guys who is getting more famous now.
Who was a in that front is the chef Ludo you don't talking about no Louis,
he just make this guy out.
No,
I swear to God he's all ready for you.
You Fuck?
He's a,
he's a,
he's a French guy.
He was doing popup restaurants here in la.
What's a pop up restaurant where they go like they find a space of an already
existing restaurant and they go from this from like a March 5th to May 1st my
restaurant is going to,
I'm an operate here during these hours in these times,
like it typically a place that does breakfast and lunch.
Let's say we're going to do dinner from now on and except he is this amazing
chef.
So it would pop up,
it would fill out every night,
would be booked out and then he would shut shop and then like go away for awhile
and do whatever he does and then be like,
Hey July I'm coming to,
you know Venice,
I'm going to take,
take place over.
I'm going to take over that one restaurant.
How does he let people know?
Well it's the word of mouth really spread.
Like my cousin is the one that let me know about it and we went there and we
ordered one of everything on the menu.
Like that's how,
cause it's not like,
it wasn't like full portion size,
it was like tasting style and it was just incredible.
And it's the kind of place you walk away and then you start telling people like
it.
That's a really spreads like wildfire.
And then now he was on a food show last year.
He's a judge on that show that Bourdain is hosting.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
What is that?
I forget he's hosting a new show.
It's a judging thing.
I think it's a food tasting thing.
And Ludo was one of the guest judges on that.
And that dude has a fried chicken truck in la that is on real.
You got to go to his food truck.
How do you find it?
Easy truck.
It's on Twitter.
It's online where you look.
Will you look for Chef Ludo owes,
uh,
fried chicken truck and did,
you can find out where it is from Twitter because you follow them and they're
like,
we're parked at,
you know,
whatever.
Hollywood boulevard.
And,
and I said,
good.
Yes,
definitely.
Always align.
Um,
when I went,
I tracked it down one time and it was,
no,
it wasn't too crazy.
It was actually,
they were actually wrapping up for the lingo truck.
Yeah.
This ain't your Mama's fried chick dude.
It's crazy.
Good.
I'm not really you.
It's
that good.
Yes.
What could be so good about it?
There's just something about the,
the richness of the flavor of the chicken.
The,
the,
um,
the breading.
Like the fried part itself is just has a flavor to it.
It's phenomenal.
And so are like the other things they have there.
I feel like Ludo truck,
you should send me some shit now.
I just really,
yeah,
you should.
What the fuck?
Ludo truck.
A little truck.
I don't know how they're gonna fuck with 'em hooked me up.
I mean,
it seems like it's like a good idea and everything like that.
But do they want is,
it's not his main thing.
Like,
oh,
I don't know.
I don't remember because how you gonna fuck with Roscoe and Melrose tonight?
How are you gonna fuck with Roscoe's if you don't have,
if you don't have waffles,
you're not gonna fuck with Roscoe.
I just started following him.
Okay.
Roscoe's Shit Roscoe's or this shit,
dude.
[inaudible]
chicken and waffles are so hard to fuck with.
It's so good.
So good.
And you get those Collard Greens with it too.
So you can give yourself an illusion of vitamins.
It's right.
I throw hot sauce all over the chicken and extra butter.
Extra Sierra hungry because you know you're going deep.
You're to know you're going to do,
you guys want to eat when to get some food after this.
All right.
He know you're going deep waffles with SMA and their American waffles.
Yeah,
those fucking big gay Belgian motherfucker shows.
Big Fluffy cloud waffles.
That's not a waffle.
That's a pastry.
That's a loaf of bread.
You fuck a real waffle house?
Little skinny tight ones that you get at a waffle house.
That's a real waffle.
You do a lot of syrup or do you do,
yeah.
I like to talk a lot of butter and a lot of syrup because I'm not trying to be
healthy.
Okay.
Oh,
the waffles asshole.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'll punish myself later at the gym.
Trust me,
I,
I'm disciplined,
but right now I'm gonna beat the fuck out of this waffle and I'm going to have a
regular coke fuck a diet coke because why play games?
Sugar,
sugar,
sugar.
Again,
I'm going to pretend that I have a diet coke.
No,
I'm going to have a regular coke and a cup of coffee.
A Cup of coffee is to allow me to stay conscious long enough to walk to the car,
get me super excited about this shit.
Right.
There should be a Roscoe's chicken and waffles and every country it's one of
those 600 words.
You don't forget it because somebody pitches it to you and you're like,
what if you have never had it?
What's that?
I'll let chickens.
Very,
very,
very good delicious fried chicken and it's very homestyle fried chicken.
Like it tastes like somebody made it in their house.
Whereas like sometimes you go to Kentucky Fried Chicken,
it's so uniform and it has like a certain amount of sodium tastes that it's like
this is a mix and you know you got,
you need Roscoe's.
It feels like somebody actually crack some eggs.
Actually dip the chicken in.
It actually rolled in and flour and deep fried the fuck out of that shit's so
Roscoe's on Pico.
I see you.
I'll see you Holla out to Roscoe's on Gower.
Yeah,
that's a beautiful combination.
It's fantastic.
Didn't seem like it would work.
You know,
if you looked at it on paper you'd be like,
how's this gonna work?
Yeah.
Chicken and why?
Why would I want to have those two together?
One of the you fuck
no,
it's perfect.
Oh boy.
You excited.
Now I want to go get chicken and waffles side of it.
So,
um,
before we wrap up,
I mean we were going to talk to them a little buddy Brian.
Sure.
And uh,
say,
what'd you think about our guests with the crazy UFO talk fell.
Oh,
well I'm being nice being nice.
I mean,
he said he could talk to aliens,
right?
He's a,
he did say that right.
At one point you sit down when he was younger,
he could,
he found a way to communicate,
meditated at a Tantrum,
thought and meditation was able to have something that he was describing that
sounded to me very much like a drug experience.
Like a psychedelic drug or a meditation experience.
Some sort of a breakthrough,
sort of a,
yeah,
I mean he seemed like a nice guy and he seemed intelligent.
But my,
my bullshit meter just was out of control and,
and,
and when that happens,
the,
the were so many things like wanted to like talk to them about,
but I also didn't want to like be confrontational or confrontation though.
I don't know man.
I don't buy any of it.
Well,
I respect the guy for coming on and talking and I don't,
you know,
I don't know whether or not he's right or telling the truth and I don't feel
it's ever true.
I mean,
I have in the past,
don't get me wrong,
I'm not a hypocrite.
I'm just a person who was involved or tried to evolve my conversational skills.
And one of the things that I try not to do is ever called bullshit.
If I'm not 100% sure I can believe I can be like,
I am positive this guy's full of shit.
But if I don't have any proof,
how can I call bullshit?
I can call bullshit on some of the things he says if they don't make any sense.
You know,
if some of the things he says don't line up with facts,
you can call bullshit on that.
But I don't really know whether or not he can actually do that until I go and
see it.
So I plan on going and seeing it.
I mean we're going to do that for that show for,
for Bam,
for question.
Everything.
We're going to go,
we're going to go out to the fucking desert.
Him,
Eddie Bravo is going to come to,
I just think it'd be perfect cause Eddie loves him some Ufo shows
and then,
and then there was like the thing where he,
he sits in his,
in the desert and he shines lasers in the sky and you know,
he says that he,
it's 100% and then you go to his youtube page to see what he's talking about is
100% and it's like one,
why is he shining?
Lasers at airplanes are up in the sky.
That's like against the law,
but to,
it's like his evidence is like,
oh,
you just see that flashing.in the middle of the sky out of nowhere.
That's his alien communication.
And that could be a million things.
You know,
you see a little flashing guy.
It could be a shooting star,
it could be,
you know,
just anything.
It's way wackier than that gets
way wackier than that.
There's actually video that I watched after the interview that I really wish I
had watched before.
I,
you know,
you can only watch so much of that stuff,
right.
But where he said that he was,
uh,
he was leading a crew and that they were of a craft at one point in time,
it was an interdimensional craft,
their standing in the middle of field and they sense that he,
he was like,
and some people said they saw me disappear for a moment and as I,
you know,
crossed into this area and that we,
we could see it in front of you.
Like it was sort of like a fog.
Well,
you know,
what we know is real
fog.
Fog is fucking real.
Okay.
So if you see fog,
you should assume that shit is fog and I fucking spaceship.
Okay.
What was that thing at the handoffs?
So like I might have got this wrong,
but it sounded like he said you can buy the movie and then once you buy it you
can put it for sale on your website.
And then you know,
like it almost sounded like he was saying like it's a pyramid scheme.
Well it's not a pyramid scheme.
It's a promotional scheme,
a pyramid scheme.
There's really no nothing of value.
The way a pyramid scheme works is you get money when you get other people to put
in money.
So like say if you're the guy who starts a scheme and you have three people that
are in that are in the scheme with you and you say,
listen,
if you get a dude to give 100 bucks for every hundred bucks,
you get 25 bucks and they start making money.
That's what I'm saying.
That's not a pyramid scheme.
You know what?
You don't understand it.
A pyramid scheme is at the end you find there's nothing of value.
And at the end what it is is that it depends on more people donating money.
Then there's people extracting money and as soon as the people want their money,
you're fucked because there's no money.
That's what happened with,
um,
that,
uh,
that it's called a Ponzi scheme.
That's what happened with Bernie Madoff.
Yeah,
that's what it was.
It was,
there was no actual value to anything.
What he's doing is he's offering you,
he has this video.
Okay,
and if you put a link on your site and he's selling the video for five bucks,
he's selling a product and if he's selling this video for five bucks,
if you put a link on your site and the clicks go through your site,
it registers.
And so you get a piece,
whatever that piece is,
it's negotiated.
Whether it's 10 cents a video or a dollar a video or whatever the fuck it is.
I don't know how much you get,
but whatever you get,
he's saying that he wanted to do that to spread the wealth and encourage people
to promote the video because it would be financially profitable for them as
well,
which is actually admirable.
I mean,
that's a cool way to do things.
If you decided to put a link on your site and you made $1,000 in a month off of
his video,
that's your money man.
And you helped him.
You helped him,
you got the video out,
which is what he wanted and you got to,
you got some money.
So nothing wrong with that.
It's not a pyramid scheme.
A real pyramid scheme is a lie because there's nothing of value.
But this isn't a,
this is a movie.
I know what you're saying.
This is an actual product.
What is the movie?
It's called serious.
It's,
uh,
his,
his whole thing is,
it's very sketch.
Okay.
And it's,
uh,
I,
I look,
I should say first of all,
that I don't disbelieve in aliens.
I don't disbelieve in the idea that we've been contacted before,
but I have never seen anything that was compelling to me as far as like visual
evidence.
As far as,
um,
eye witness testimony.
I've never seen anything compelling that made me 100% sure that that person had
seen something from another planet or that this video was something from another
planet.
I've seen some wild shit,
but I don't know exactly what it is and I'm not,
I'm not privy to all of the various pieces of information that go into,
you know,
whatever the fuck happened.
When we see a thing that's flying across the sky,
who knows what that is.
One of the things I asked him,
he said,
we have a photo of a,
of a being.
It's like it looks like a,
an ethereal being.
I go,
how do you know that's not a video?
Or if I go,
it's not an artifact.
Well how can you,
how you,
how the fuck could you possibly know?
Like there's a lot of artifacts.
Yeah.
That hologram thing is talking about.
I'm like,
are you kidding me?
You're actually saying that's like a Hologram dude.
Or even at the photo
dimensional being looked at,
there's a lot of confirmation bias.
Yeah.
And the reality of the Ufo community,
and this is again,
this is not saying everyone,
and this is not saying that you are foes are fake,
but the reality of the Ufo community is that it's filled with Kooks.
Just like the psychic community.
Just like the big foot community,
just like the ghost community.
It doesn't mean that goats aren't real.
It doesn't mean big foot's not real.
But it means all a lot of those people are drawn to Kooky Shit.
And another thing isn't like DNA nowadays fast enough where you take a little
piece of that little alien dude,
you could just be like,
oh yeah,
it's a baby.
Well not only that,
did you know that that alien dude,
they found that fucking thing and like 2002 yeah,
they found that thing a long ass time ago
or at Michael's craft shop or would they find this thing?
They found it in the dirt somewhere.
Yeah.
He didn't want to tell us where he found it.
He found it in a desert safe.
What do you said afterwards?
We're never supposed to repeat.
So be careful.
Oh yeah.
Cause he told us where it's being studied and shit.
But the bottom line is he set himself up.
Okay,
so here's,
here's either they do the genetic work and it really is being done.
That's High Level Ivy League school.
And we find out about it and we get like peer reviewed papers that are talking
about whatever the fuck this thing is.
Whether it's a dis,
like some sort of a fetus,
it's got birth defects and makes it look like that.
I mean who knows what the hell it is or completely artificial or you know,
whatever.
Well you know w if they actually run a test,
but to say that you did a test and to say you got results coming,
you'll set yourself up because it's one or the other.
Now it's either bullshit or it's something.
Yeah.
And if it's a rubber doll,
I'm going to be upset at you.
Of course.
Yeah.
I think that's a test that it,
it's like a week,
a week.
DNA.
I think it takes that long.
Like if there's a fire in a car,
the police can go,
okay,
we found human remains cause we checked its DNA as human DNA.
Isn't that something fast?
I don't know.
How does he not know how to use a camera yet?
I'm sorry.
Well,
let's,
let's Google the whole,
just a guest you had on the big foot thing.
He's the biggest big a phone.
Well he only saw two bone saw to Dr. Greer.
Hold on.
Dr. Greer,
ideally in a top sea.
Oh,
all of those are fucking bullshit.
The autopsy films.
Um,
Dr. Greer,
alien body.
I just don't like it if he is,
if he's a bullshitter,
bullshitting is,
I am going to send shit to his house.
Okay.
I'll just say this.
At least a small percentage of what he was saying smelled like bullshit.
The anecdotal stories,
the way they were,
they were coming out.
Somebody described them like,
like bad scenes in a movie.
Then he said this and I said that sometimes people just sort of paraphrase
though and that could be responding to me.
You're telling a story over and over and over again after a course of so many
years.
Sometimes people sort of paraphrase what actually was said and they put it into
almost like a script form.
And that could have been what that guy was doing.
Cause it did sound like fiction.
Yeah.
It also sounded like,
I noticed that whenever you would ask him a question and that kind of throw them
off or whatever,
he would go into this weird voice where he just suddenly good.
Yeah.
So like it got really quiet and calm like,
yeah.
Hmm.
Like his voice changed into this.
We're really weird volume.
It just went.
Those were three of us.
They think they have an alien body or that thing.
What do you think that is?
I think that's a very old human body.
Six inches long.
But they have a math and a ruler next to it and everything,
but couldn't that be from it's fuck.
Of course it could be a child or it could be so old that it's like when the,
but he doesn't know.
He said,
I mean in his defense he said he doesn't know what it is and he said they're
doing tests on it.
Yeah,
but if he found it that long ago,
I don't know when he got ahold of it though.
He told us,
I don't remember.
It was a long conversation and we talked,
we talked to the guy for three hours.
It's going to be,
hey guys.
Yeah,
we ran,
says it was a guy years ago in January of 2013 and it says that the studies will
take around two months,
possibly longer.
So they just started the testing in January.
So that's why they haven't gotten these,
doing these testing.
Mcafee,
McAfee,
what happened at McAfee?
Mcafee,
he's balling.
He's in a Texas trying to sell his house and believes dude,
dude,
dude.
Yeah,
he's got his 20 year old Third World Hottie with them just getting this freak.
Huh.
Good for him.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know man.
You know,
if he really did find an alien,
like Holy Shit.
I mean maybe can you imagine?
That would be really fascinating and ironic if there was a guy who was a
charlatan who was a,
a total UFO hoaxer but somebody gave him a real alien.
You know?
And I'm not saying that Greer is a charlatan.
I don't think he is.
I think,
um,
first of all he's dealing with a really nutty group of humans,
the Ufo community.
And I think if that's your,
your base and that you're communicating with them only for decade after decade.
And most of this was sort of instigated on your part before the Internet.
So he was involved in like the Ufo community before,
you know,
people were even online a lot before Twitter,
before you in my space.
Like he was online,
you know,
like,
and he was known through the world from these youtube clips and shit like that.
He was already,
before that,
it had been long before the disclosure project,
he had put that together for years.
So he had always been involved.
All these nutty people.
Yeah.
And when you're involved with nutty people,
especially the nutty Ufo people before the Internet,
like you got a lot of adjusting to do.
Once the,
the,
the Thor Hammer of reality comes down and sometimes guys adjust really poorly.
So they still have a lot of bullshit in their game.
You know,
they might have a few things that are real that they're investigating that are
beyond understanding there.
It's very possible.
But there also might be some fuckery mixed in there too.
And Leo Fuckery,
serious writers.
And you've gotta be real careful.
And one of the things is he's,
uh,
somehow or another he's drawing an income from all of this.
He wasn't really that open about it,
but I know that he takes people out into the desert and gives them an alien
encounters and shit and they charges money for that.
Of course.
Yeah.
And it's like several days and you'd take a bunch of people out there and you
know,
make some cash,
some shit in the sky almost makes me want to say that you shouldn't even bother
dealing with this one.
It's so obvious.
No,
no,
no.
It's both.
It's fascinating.
He's a,
he's a certainly marketing himself and he certainly brought up his site a lot,
but it's also,
here's the question,
what would you do if you knew that there really was some sort of encounter with
humans and aliens?
If you knew that there had been a series of events that had been swept under the
rug and covered up and you start making a living doing something different,
but this fascination with Ufo gets in the way and then all of a sudden you have
to quit your job and then as you're quitting your job for something that you
absolutely believe in,
but it's totally ridiculed by everyone around you,
then what if you have to figure out how to make a living off of this thing that
you built?
So maybe it's that maybe the guy's legit and may,
but it's this,
this trying to profit off of it,
which gets people to go ahead and what's your motive?
Hey,
how can I got to pay you to go to the desert?
you do with all the money that he got from his donated movie.
Hey,
how much did you claim on your taxes?
Where'd you get that money?
Where's it?
Where's it coming from?
You writing books,
you're selling the books,
you're doing lectures,
you're doing this,
you're taking people out in the desert.
You're profiting,
okay?
It's,
this is obviously how you make your living.
Now,
not that there's anything wrong with that,
if he's legit,
if he's sincere,
but when you have those elements,
people automatically get skeptical and then there's the part of like
extraordinary claims require extraordinary evidence and when you're claiming
crazy shit,
you should have photos and video ready to go at the drop of a hat.
And when I was questioning him about where can I see these photos?
Like if you have photos you shouldn't.
First of all,
if you have something that's really important for people to see and you are a
researcher and your whole Gig is about trying to get the truth out,
you would put that shit online the moment you got it right,
he would make sure it goes viral.
If you're holding it back and only putting it in your documentary,
I got to go,
all right.
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean,
I see you trying to make some money,
but what you're doing is contrary to the,
the,
the path that you need to follow to be taken
and serious,
especially a scientific path because somebody that wants to tell you the truth
about,
uh,
you know,
a huge something that would have that type of impact on the world and the way it
operates.
You don't go as,
as somebody that's pursued this for my whole life,
I have the answer.
I want you to give me five bucks first before I tell you about it.
B,
I mean,
again,
I have to be fair.
It also could be that he doesn't understand how he's coming off.
It also could be true that,
you know,
he really truly has had these experiences,
but now he's in a scramble to try to figure out how to make some money off of
it.
There's a fascinating website that details Hillary Clinton's meetings with the
Rockefeller family.
It's really crazy.
And one of the photos,
Hillary Clinton,
it's walking and she's got this book with her and people tried to figure out
what book it was like they're there.
They did a close up of the image and it's a book on extraterrestrial encounters
and art.
It's about,
are we alone in the universe?
And the book is all about like what we would do if we got contacted by an alien
race and she's walking with Rockefeller who had given her that book.
Really?
Yeah.
So she's walking along in his ranch in Wyoming.
He's worth about a fucking billion,
trillion dollars.
He's at the top of the financial food chain.
And he's exactly the person that this guy,
Dr. Steven Greer was telling us we'd have access to this kind of information and
would want to,
uh,
you know,
figure out what we do.
You know,
what do we do about the banking system,
what we do about the military.
So what do we do when,
if,
when and if aliens do come.
And so he's walking around and meeting a woman who ran for president.
It was the wife of the president of the secretary of state and then wandering
around is fucking a ranch and she's got an alien book in her hand,
but he gave her,
now that was that photo.
The original photo was,
good question.
Is it,
is it published anywhere?
Respectable,
you know,
like,
cause that's,
that's,
Yup.
Seems
like a very good question.
Usually photo.
You're very good question.
So let's,
let's,
let's search for the hoax Hillary Clinton and everything you could do is take
the Hillary Clinton photo and save it to your desktop and then Google image
search it and find that similar images and see if they all have that because
somebody has made that a twilight book cover for sure.
Okay.
Let's see if it's Hillary Clinton Rockefeller alien book,
shades of grey,
50 shades of grey.
Mm.
Well there's a,
there's also some documents about,
um,
about,
uh,
Rockefeller wanting to talk President Clinton into,
these were released by the freedom of Information Act that Rockefeller was
trying to talk President Clinton into,
um,
into,
uh,
releasing information about aliens.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And the Rockefeller was requesting information and they wouldn't give it to him.
And he had a meeting with Clinton.
Yeah.
It's just a pretty trippy man.
The book Laurance Rockefeller apparently was fascinated with [inaudible].
He was,
uh,
the dude was,
he was obsessed.
Yeah.
Maybe he's just like,
you know,
just like you,
maybe just a little guy that likes aliens and conspiracies.
Yeah.
It could be just that's it.
That's how simple it is,
you know,
except he could actually call the government asked for cash or asked to,
uh,
to give them cash for things.
You mean he like established funds and shit.
He,
along with his niece and Bartley,
the stepdaughter of Winthrop Rockefeller and the then president of the
Rockefeller Family Fund,
he established the Ufo disclosure initiative to the Clinton White House.
They asked for all UFO information held by the government,
including from the CIA and the u s air force to be declassified and released to
the public.
The first and most important test case where declassification had to apply
according to Rockefeller was the Roswell Ufo incident.
This is fascinating.
Like why,
why didn't,
um,
Greer talk about this,
why doesn't he know about this?
Cause this is all,
these are all government freedom of information documents.
It seems like something you would be into if you were dedicated to the cause.
Yeah,
it was in 1995 the Clintons went to a talk to the Rockefellers.
It was when Hilary was,
uh,
married to bill and bill was the president and a mother fucker gave her a book
on aliens.
Come walk with me.
Let's talk.
I want to talk to about something from,
talk to you about some real shit and tell your daddy go home and tell Daddy.
I want to know,
tell,
tell bill till Beal.
I want to know what's up everyday.
I get to say that my dad is Dansk.
Yeah.
Creepy old fuck knows so fucking creepy.
And Bill Clinton apparently couldn't,
you know,
according to a Rockefeller or according to,
um,
the people talked about this,
Bill Clinton couldn't,
couldn't get any information out of him.
They didn't want to tell him I shut him down.
That's one of the things that Greer was saying.
Greer was saying that,
um,
these presidents,
like,
people that want to get access to information that they don't,
it's not like you become president.
Okay,
come on.
We're going to tell you what's up.
Like,
no,
you don't need to know that.
You just need to be the president.
Yeah,
go do your shit.
But I'm like,
well,
who does know?
And then that's the real,
that's the real weird part.
Yeah.
If he is right,
that is how I think it would go down if he's telling the truth.
I really do think that the people,
st people that can keep something as crazy as the federal bank in place when
it's not really a branch of the federal government at all,
but they call it the federal bank.
The same people that can keep the military industrial complex moving in the same
rate that is moving now.
Those would be the people that would know about the Ufos.
I mean,
there must be,
if you,
if you believe that corporations control the earth,
which it's Kinda obvious at this corporation from everything,
it's this guy to beat people at the head of these corporations.
Who are these people?
Like these old dudes with this fucking Ufo book.
Yeah.
So he might be right.
It could be right.
What do you think Brian's right?
How dare you just throw that out there like that?
No,
I actually don't know.
I want to believe him by,
you know,
there's just too much fishy in my mouth.
There's definitely a potential for fuckery.
I did a lot of fuckery.
That little creature thing that drives me the most crazy cause.
I mean it's,
it's just slow to me.
It's just like,
all right,
wait,
so we're going to find out the day that the movie releases.
Is that set up that way?
You know what I mean?
Thank you.
Said it was going to cut.
It was,
the information was coming.
Come out that week.
He got to come with me though,
man.
You gotta come.
What's going to be fun?
We should film it.
What are you gonna go through it?
We're going to go to this premiere premiere of his movie.
He definitely,
now I'm going to have to wear a wig or something.
We can go.
He didn't say anything like you said what you believe.
He didn't do anything wrong.
Prove me wrong.
Look,
the Internet is probably predominantly on your side.
The Internet is pro.
If I had to guess.
I know my message board,
and this is no disrespect to Dr. Greer,
but my message board,
90% of them thought he was full of Shit.
Yeah.
90.
And I'm not bullshitting.
When I looked at the,
uh,
the thread,
it was pretty overwhelming that most people were calling fuckery.
Yeah.
But that's again,
when you make an extraordinary claim,
you have to provide extraordinary evidence.
And if you don't have that extraordinary evidence,
it becomes very difficult to convince people.
So if he really did have these experiences and he really does know all this
information,
that's all well and good,
but you can't go around telling people unless you have something
Shelby,
the hard evidence,
I don't want to hear it.
And,
and it can't be,
you have to open the store and take this ride.
You got to be able to just show people harder than,
I mean,
I guess you do.
What do you do though for an alien really does abducted you really does take you
away if you really do know what the fuck do you do if there is no evidence that
you can get what I'm saying.
If your best evidence is watch my film,
then it leads people to embrace not believing you.
Yeah,
I agree.
You know?
And right now it looks like that DNA test to find out like a simple basic DNA
test to see if it's something is human or it takes less
than 24 hours,
less than 24 hours to find out if something's human.
Yeah.
Meaning like if I,
if I threw a piece of Bologna at you and you're like,
oh my God,
that's a human,
you can take it to the DNA lab and they'll go,
no,
it's Baloney.
Hmm.
Okay.
So would they be able to distinguish between an animal and I'm like a monkey
baby or a monkey fetus or a human feet?
Would they be like,
yeah,
it's pretty much you just the human markup,
you know,
d our human DNA is,
what's the smallest monkey?
Uh,
what's his name?
This is a real,
it's a really tiny monkey,
right?
There's a tiny spider monkey there.
They're way bigger.
There's some really small primates.
What it maybe it was like a dried out,
really small crime.
I mean it doesn't necessarily have to be even a human finger monkey.
I wonder how long it would take to find out whether or not something like,
wow,
look how small that is.
Yeah,
that's pretty small.
and if that was all like,
oh it's hair fell off and some of the its tail.
That's what it looked like.
That came out of my belly button.
That probably lives in your asshole.
Probably don't even know about it.
He lives in there.
It's like a mouse in the house.
The happiest little monkey.
He's got a little fucking set up in there.
Brian's ass.
He's got a barrier.
He sets up whenever Brian's taking a shit cause past it blocks off in the area
that he's got cordoned off in Brian's after his house.
He helps jungle hot,
push the shit out.
Do you have a hard time shifting Brian?
No.
It's almost like someone's pushing it because someone is,
you've got to fucking little monkey man with a shovel and puppet shit out of
here.
I don't act like he wouldn't enjoy it.
Stop shaking your head.
This monkey my ass too late.
All right,
let's go get some neat.
It's fucking shows over.
Tommy [inaudible].
How can people get your,
uh,
your uh,
CD?
Oh,
you can go to Tom cigarette.com and click on the store or you can go to iTunes.
Powerful iTunes,
powerful iTunes.
And My site also has a link to,
um,
if you don't use iTunes because people are always want an option that's not
iTunes.
Right?
There's a link.
You can download it from CD baby on a link on my site.
Nice.
Christina and I are going to do alive your mom's house comedy tour.
So we're going to Seattle,
um,
May 18th,
and then,
uh,
I think we're going to do Portland the next day,
but the Seattle link is up.
I just tweeted,
are you doing both comedy and also just lifestyle lifestyle,
a lot.
Podcasts.
Excuse me.
Just to know.
Podcasts can,
I'm saying it's the two of us.
We don't ever ride together.
It's the two.
That's awesome.
Really Fun.
So it should be a good time.
I've never done that before.
Really.
I always thought you guys would have done that a long time ago.
Yeah.
I mean,
because of the popularity of your podcasts you allowed to put together shit like
this.
It's all from the podcast.
He's just done the hundredth episode.
I heard and I heard you had an awesome guests.
Red Banded our,
we did our hundredth episode,
man.
We talked about how you are the one that got us started with it.
So that was pretty cool.
I'm so happy.
Did and so have you been experiencing a lot more people coming out to fans of
the show is definitely.
And there's a best fans.
They're the most amazing people at the shows.
So yeah,
I got,
I got a bunch of,
um,
it's been great.
And our goal is to get to the point where we can do what we're doing in Seattle
and I'm in a bunch of different places.
Yeah.
Um,
and still play like the good clubs that we love playing,
but try to take a little more control of where we're doing it and what we're
doing.
You know?
I mean,
you should be able to book shit now because your,
your podcast has been going on for a couple of years now.
How many years?
It's a,
we're over two.
So we're going into our third year.
Yeah.
That's strong.
So yeah,
it's amazing how if you just stick with something all of a sudden,
boom.
There's two years con.
Yeah.
With us three.
It's crazy.
We're three years in that.
And you guys,
I remember doing,
I was telling somebody I'm on one of your first 15.
Yeah.
Sitting on a couch.
And I just remember we'd lean up.
You're like,
sit closer to the mic man.
Sit back and then you're like say close.
But I kept scooching back.
But yeah.
And then now you have a whole goddamn studio.
Yeah.
We resisted it for a long time.
They really embraced it now.
Now.
Yeah.
Well now it's,
um,
it's more important than anything else I do.
I know.
Now it's more important than,
I mean it's really,
I hate to say it's more important than the UFC as far as like for my standup
gigs,
it's way more important like this,
uh,
this weekend,
one of the things,
it's a trippy is a,
our buddy,
Tony's era from the,
our message board came down this weekend and it was interesting hearing him talk
about the difference in the shows.
Like he used to come see me at,
uh,
the punchline when I was there,
you know,
the punchline and Columbus,
what isn't funny?
Bone Columbus funnybone funny bone and kilometers,
great club.
There's a little tiny place,
but this time we're at the palace theater and there's fucking 2,400 people
there.
It was,
it was crazy.
Huge.
Yeah.
And it's this beautiful a place in it's packed and he was like,
the nutty thing was like,
people were so nice and friendly and between all the jokes,
everybody was like real quiet,
respectful.
He goes,
it was nuts.
it was fucking nuts.
Everyone's got desk,
quad tee shirts on or higher prime eight tee shirts.
It's like this crazy.
It's pretty positive,
fun environment and all of that's attributed to the podcast.
It's all attributable to people that,
you know,
they've seen the podcast,
they've seen her stand up like it's changed everything man.
It changes.
The world has changed the world for is constantly rattling off.
If you haven't seen Diaz's podcast,
it's the church of what's happening now.
You could get it on iTunes.
If you'd go to mad flavor on Twitter,
you can find out when he's doing them alive.
I did his a weeks ago,
told me a story about when he went to football camp as a kid and it was Jack
Lambert football camp.
You Remember Jack Lambert?
No.
Is it very famous?
Pittsburgh Steeler linebacker w uh,
like had his teeth missing cause he was such a fucking,
you know,
animal.
Yeah.
And he walked into the bathroom and Jack Lambert was taking a shit in one of
those old school locker rooms where they don't have doors on the style.
Right.
And that he was shaving in the shit water and
almost fucking had a heart attack.
So that's old school.
If you want to laugh your Dick off,
go to go to Joey's,
a church of what's happening now where I'm a guest on and he tells that story
and it's Piss your pants.
I'm going to get that and listened to on the way home.
It's so fun.
The iPod APP,
the iPhone podcast APP is amazing.
He's awesome.
I was bored with people,
Shit that I had on my iPod.
Why?
I Dunno like horrible reviews.
I think it's great.
I think there's,
I have no problem.
I mean I use stitcher,
but people hate everything to hate themselves.
90% of the hate you getting out of all these people in line is they hate
themselves.
I went to a restaurant the other day,
they got three stars and I read the reviews like so many people would just
shitting on it to.
It was amazing because I had heard it was amazing.
People like,
oh there's this new Italian restaurant opened.
It's so good.
It's not cheap.
I mean it's,
it's pricey,
but the dishes were fantastic in la.
It's out in um,
like West hills,
but it was a like five star restaurants,
like in my eyes I was like,
wow,
this place is amazing.
It's really good.
The Pasta was fresh pasta,
you know,
it's like the way they,
I mean,
it was legit.
Then I read the reviews.
It's like people are just constant.
People get upset about restaurants when they didn't get the seat,
when they thought they were going to get it though one star.
Absolutely.
This is a fucking shit.
There was a hostess and you're like,
all right,
or waiter spilled water,
Lonestar fuck you.
But in the podcast APP,
I'm like,
the other day I was in my car and I said,
you know what,
I'd like to listen to Dan Carlin's hardcore history.
So I'm at a fucking red light.
Okay.
And I go,
I have time,
man,
the single parent real quick at a red light and the time that it took for the
light to create,
I go hardcore history,
doom.
It opens up Mongols think play bank play,
play.
It's playing and it's playing on my fucking car through Bluetooth.
Just like that.
Instantly streaming tomatoes.
Perfect,
not a glitch in it.
And for the next hour home,
I listened to the history of the Mongol Empire,
uh,
which is fascinating.
Dan Carlin's hardcore history.
We had them as a guest on the podcast a couple of weeks ago and now I'm a,
I'm addicted to his,
uh,
his podcast.
It's excellent to me if you're into like crazy stories about history and the
wars and this whole shit about Gingiss con,
this is a series that he's doing right now.
It's hot.
It's so nuts.
I was only 12,
1200.
There was a few,
a few hundred years ago.
This motherfucker was just carving its way across the world.
Yeah,
I'd love to listen to that.
Amazing.
And I got it immediately at a red light with that podcast APP.
So if you don't like the podcast App,
go fuck your soul and introduces you to the podcasting to so many fans too that
you didn't know existed.
Like you always tend to think of,
I mean,
you've had obviously like way more exposure and,
and you know,
being on television,
but like,
you forget like when you do
just the podcasts that,
you know,
there's people downloading it in all over Canada,
all over Australia,
UK and like all over the world,
all over the world and that and that now like we can go and do like,
I'm going to do Toronto and it's all because of the podcast.
I'm doing that underground comedy club.
I heard a place is awesome.
That's fucking awesome.
I'm going there in May talking.
Just got back from there.
Yes.
He said it was a fucking incredible experience.
I'm so excited to go.
I'm going to get really weak early in May.
You and the beautiful thing about podcasts and,
uh,
the impact of podcasts is that it,
if people don't like the podcast,
it's not successful.
It's really that simple,
right?
They don't,
they don't take off unless people like them.
So it's,
no one's promoting it.
It's totally democratic.
It's totally organic.
It totally ha it either happens or it doesn't happen.
Right.
So the two people that enjoy our podcast.
Thank you very much.
We appreciate the fuck out of it.
I know you do.
You have some shade.
Absolutely.
It's like the greatest opportunity to have your own show that could have ever
existed.
Absolutely.
There's nothing else.
Nothing else that comes close to giving you the kind of freedom.
We're number one right now.
No.
And all comedy podcasts suck.
Suck,
suck,
suck upon it.
Uh,
but we're,
we're very happy,
so thank you everybody that came out this weekend.
Um,
uh,
Brian say thanks.
Yes,
thank you very much.
Everyone was so nice,
so nice and a pretty powerful death squad.
A group there.
They'd have a hundred people before the show even started met at this.
Uh,
it's weird.
They're starting to like,
like chapters in every state.
Organic,
Ricky,
completely organic desk.
Quite Ohio,
Connecticut called Florida.
Completely organic.
I hear you.
We have Juggalos.
Yeah,
we basically have juggalos.
we have a new type of juggle.
Oh,
though it's like fight club.
They're nice.
They get their shit together.
Eating Kale shakes,
lifting weights.
I talked to a hundred people that lost fucking a hundred pounds or more.
I mean,
I'm not joking.
I keep,
I talked to 30 people this weekend instead of changed their life.
And it happens every time we do shows the,
the weirdness of it all.
And the unexpectedness of it all is the inspirational aspect of it.
I never thought that that was going to happen.
Never thought that people are going to take these crazy rants just getting
pissed off and talking shit about things or breaking things down and take,
take them and put them into youtube clips and then those youtube clips would get
hundreds of thousands of views.
I mean,
it's millions or some of them.
It's,
it's,
it's really crazy.
It's incredible.
And I don't know how it happened.
You affect people's lives,
but it's,
it's,
it's all organic.
It was no one ever planned to do any of this.
And that's the most beautiful thing about it.
Uh,
I'm headed right now from here.
We're going to get some neat and then I'm going to go do,
um,
uh,
David shows podcasts.
Looking forward to that.
Love that dude.
You got to come to ours,
told let's make it happen.
Powerful Thompson Guerra,
follow him on Twitter.
Tom S E G U R,
a m and follow red band on Twitter,
r e d.
B.
A.
N.
If you go to desk squad.tv,
you can find information on all the different shows that,
uh,
you know,
Brian,
we'll put on a show like every month or so.
And including this Friday night at the ice house in the little room,
which is the dopest room the whole time I might come down to,
I want to see what I'm doing Friday night,
but if I have time,
I'm going to,
I'm going to come down and do a set.
Um,
Wednesday the 13th,
March 14th,
14th we have Tony Sigora a Yoshi is Honi the girl who the fuck is Tony?
Tony Hinchcliffe.
Hence Cliff Yoshi.
Yoshi just joined us.
Yeah.
Billy Bono and Jason Tebow at the American Comedy Co.
March 14th.
That's next Thursday.
Tickets or at American Comedy Co.
Dot Com.
Gotcha.
And that is a really dope little place.
It's awesome.
Oh,
I have to Yoshi people that are asking me about Montreal.
Montreal was sold out a long time ago.
I'm there with powerful,
Ari should fear we're doing the gym comedy club.
It's the tiniest little place.
It seats like no bullshit.
Like I don't even think it seats a hundred people.
Really?
Yeah.
The last time I was there I did.
Um,
the palladium,
I think it's called like two 2100 people.
And then you're doing a tiny yeah.
Yeah.
But it's my friend Jimbo.
See,
I've been working for Jimbo for,
since I think I first worked for him in [inaudible] 92.
[inaudible] 93.
Yeah,
it's somewhere around then.
It was before I ever moved to California.
I was living in New York.
This is really cool.
And uh,
he's just the nicest guy ever.
And he's so nice.
I alternate whenever I do Montreal,
when I do Montreal,
I'd do a big theater and then the next time I come in town,
it's a few months later,
whatever it is,
I do his tiny club.
That's cool.
Yeah.
That's so good.
It's fun for me.
You know,
it's fun to do.
It's a cool ass place,
but unfortunately it's sold out pitch.
That's really cool.
Joe.
You've got way cooler.
It's,
it's an awesome place.
And then the 22nd and the 23rd is the next time on the road I'm going to be,
it's Zucchinis in Nashville,
another small club.
I got a gang of new shit that I'm working on and so I decided to book myself in
a really small place and uh,
[inaudible] and Nashville is fucking great.
It's,
that's a the 22nd and 23rd.
Um,
so that's,
um,
I'm just trying to like,
put all this shit into a form.
I'm going to try it.
I'm trying to do my next special in August.
He really,
yeah.
Damn.
I'm trying to figure out where to do it.
Yeah,
I've got an hour and 20 minutes now.
This,
this past weekend,
it was so solid.
It was like this new shit that I have.
It's like a lot of it is ideas that I've had before.
I just didn't know where to put them and you know,
so it's coming along really quick,
so I figured fuck it.
Let's get that ball rolling again.
That's cause I,
yeah,
cause I want to,
um,
I want to,
I have a new process that I'm doing and one of the new processes is a work on
what I have now add to it but also stockpile.
So I'm doubling up on my writing.
So I'm trying to have four big writing sessions a week.
That's my goal is to get for like major
writing sessions a week.
So three days,
I don't read it all,
but for several hour writing sessions,
just write,
write,
write one blog a week.
So that's my other new goal.
Is your writing session just freeform writing.
Just like whatever.
Like to sit down stream of conscious.
Yeah,
whatever I want to write about.
That's cool.
Yeah.
It could be sports,
could be my deck.
Could be poop deck with your sports.
Could Be Dick and poop with sports.
Yeah.
That sounds like a good show.
That's a good show.
Dick and poop with sports,
that's like a good,
like over two radio guys that talk shit and don't want anybody to know their
name.
I'm Dick and this is poop.
We're dicking poop.
It's sports.
All right,
you fox.
Listen,
we love the shit out of you people.
And uh,
we,
we appreciate all of your support.
We appreciate all the,
the,
the positive energy that we get.
I say this all the time,
but I can't say it enough.
It's a,
we feel incredibly fortunate.
It's a very unusual place to be in,
in life.
And,
uh,
you know,
um,
I,
I understand that and I appreciate that and I'm very thankful.
Uh,
so people keep coming to,
please don't stop doing the podcast.
I've never stopped doing this fucking podcast.
I'll quit a lot of shit in this life,
but I'm not gonna quit this podcast.
We will always produce it in some form or another.
Go to rogan.ting.com to support our sponsor ting sign up.
They'll give you 25 bucks,
either off the service or off one of their groovy phones.
Go to [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t.
Use a code name Brogan and save yourself 10% off any and all supplements.
Tomorrow.
We have diamond David Lee Roth,
one of the baddest mother motherfuckers to ever walk the face of the planet.
He will be here tomorrow.
And then Friday,
of course,
Dr Amit Goswami,
and uh,
he's gonna school us on the nature of reality hooks.
You crazy fucks.
All right.
We love you.
We'll talk to you soon.
Thank you.
Bye.